[Music]
foreign
around talk to him
how we doing Sunday Sunday Sunday
how we doing how my levels are selling
how am I doing out here
what's going on hustle I see you what's
going on silver lab guy what's going on
I see you let's get some shout outs
right quick my ninja squirrel okay Nola
oranges what's going on
Jorgensen all right no doubt what's
going on Sunday Sunday so wagon all
right so FCC holding line okay I don't
know what they what they doing right now
but it is what it is Hollywood rolls
what's going on talk to me all my levels
are Saturday what's going on Mason
what's up boss red77 what's up IMAX
what's going on Takata what's going on
Mr glass was going on I appreciate you
hustle no yeah Super Mario I was
thinking about you on that I was like yo
he got to be going crazy you said that
when he was on um when you came on we
had you on as a guest void lock what's
going on Thomas Bellotti was going on
Dusty was going on civil lab I see you
finally here to be live yeah we gotta go
and we got it going thank you for the
level check Adidas 20-0
no down yeah we gotta go but we gotta go
we're going to see what's going on we
got these spicy topics spoke King
already you know I mean got a chance to
to build with the guard yesterday in the
Statue Community we're talking about
that for a little bit and uh then we
gotta get to these topics gotta get to
these topics try to see what's going on
with uh solve and addicts see what's
going on with them child of God gaming I
like that the child of God the right
hand of Zeus
Mr glasses going on Gerald Mack the OG
Bay Area Stand Up Man Without Fear are
we gonna see Buck today
um
[Music]
but a lot of information came out so you
know the realm wants us to talk about it
shout out to attic for making me uh talk
about it because I actually wasn't going
to talk about it oh man that proof is
going on so yeah
he got like yeah I love that day addict
with disease how you in the chat with
disease but you ain't in the podcast
with me
uh somebody had a rough night all right
get yourself in here no doubt happy 2070
oh Reasonable Doubt 27 years word oh man
22 devils and all that man yeah Jay had
an album that was an album that was a
classic we give it to him Alex what's
going on Kyle let's go Xbox no doubt so
yeah we're gonna get a attic and
everybody up in here you know what I'm
saying I have a good show lined up for
you it's right in the valley like a few
minutes late or maybe right on time
depending on when these these people
come in here Diablo 4 yeah see that's
why I went offline mode for Diablo
that's the thing I guess in my nerves
plus I can't I wish I could play offline
on my allies so it's like I could just
catch up on grinding you know
you still gotta see how it's gonna go
to enter they looking strong I have to
admit they are looking very strong in
these first two days we just discussed
anyway let me give you some Dallas bars
while king and the crew gets in here and
uh yeah the cops are coming so I gotta
go
[Music]
foreign
welcome to the show if you would not
mind go hit it up find yourself a spot
get comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be using these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original you're also
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and sampling making
it flammable this is that this is that
Yoga Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up
in the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rains you
just for target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got you
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless of people don't aim
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
and I'm going places better tell her
Uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns uses a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter social or
my city but I'm still in my Coastal I
got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
hell look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing it
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all to
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and Sample and
making it flammable this is that this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
you just a Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
AIM check my vocals all on Twitter but
I'm anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Fred and Kruger that's
do that again
foreign
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go hit it up find yourself a spot
get comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start it regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords Pike
[Music]
a problem
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to an even though I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnito who cares if you fly if you
steal a mosquito you swear you ain't
something but really be Stevo you like
to collect stuff and that's cool but I
got bad news even if you really was that
joke you never still be the king of the
statue sister juvenile I've been cursed
with a curse to be Musical and if you
hate it we'll meet in The Crucible other
than nothing it's cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cause you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord okay
[Music]
you know we was talking about you
yesterday at the cookout yeah about your
manscape oh man you had somebody there
at the cookout
it was like so I've got bars
anyway uh yeah mics are hot and we're
back and we are alive here you hear you
and welcome to the iron Lord podcast LLC
also live on lordsofgaming.net episode
number 310. it's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the round table on the
Lord's date and today we've got
Microsoft versus the FTC hearings
Indiana Jones exclusive to Xbox Final
Fantasy 16 Impressions and performance
and Nintendo's latest direct to discuss
so we gonna get right into it so let's
introduce the Four Horsemen of gaming as
one of them walks away right what I'm
about to do his intro
I'm here you sell something oh okay you
got no doubt these original gaming next
to the room here at the round table my
co-host Nicole Mouse my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of his old world and the
how of the young wolf my man Lord at it
back to back attic show how we doing sir
oh my God
this part is this part of the game
you want to be famous you want to be
famously famous now now you're famous
an intro not not that that's you it's uh
it's been pretty good but just got
through playing some Final Fantasy 16.
nice wow
you can clearly see sometimes it does
drop there's no denying clearly clearly
it does drop Jesus you can tell what
king was to talk about yeah
[Laughter]
so that's been it what else been going
on
uh pretty much Final Fantasy I've been
playing a lot of uh NDA stuff that I
can't really talk about but uh dude out
here yeah I know I I I I embrace it I
love you man okay okay A little doubt
with that exclusive Deuces we can't talk
about what anyway that's been it sir
yeah pretty much uh currently you know I
did I did catch up on I realized there
was a bunch of Texas Chainsaw Massacre
movies I've never seen
and me uh I watched a few of those
yesterday and I'm sitting here watching
these and I'm just like these are the
same movies and I don't know and I'm not
against that right yeah they don't
really there's no there's no
continuation of story it's just the same
story over and over
no doubt and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo game who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also that's ostradamus
the Lord of clarity and lower patreon of
the iron bank PC Master race his own
Lord Sovereign how we doing on that Ally
I'm good I'm good on the airline been
playing this week I got to play some
games yesterday I was home so I actually
got to play games yesterday
[Laughter]
so I I just what I do is I do exhibition
with the live rosters I have the my
roster the latest roster which for the
Yankees is just destroyed there's nobody
on there
um yeah I know the Mets pain is yeah I
don't want to talk about it
so and I did that and this is the thing
I'm not a game mode dude I never have
been right because GameBoy game mode has
traditionally taken the game and kind of
washed out the colors and it's you have
the latency right but but everything
else just look kind of disgusting until
now
the OLED situation is a lot lot
different
okay the brightness the colors the way
they pop and then all the other stuff in
games 120 hertz the vrr the uh
Whatchamacallit the freesync premium oh
I can at the same time I'm like oh my
God crazy so it's funny like I use Pulse
Pitching right
yep the thing is my timing is off
because the latency is so low now it's
so non-existent that the timing that I
had built in for it prior doesn't work
anymore I'm missing
bombs off of me I'm like hold up
but but it's beautiful it's beautiful
I'm having fun with that and I went I
was on the finally on the PC again that
I haven't played for a minute and I was
playing some uh some friends even before
trying to get through Resident Evil 4
the Remake all right bro man yo that's a
game that just it doesn't leave you
alone ever it's you get out of one
situation and it's like nah nah more
drama more beef and then and then Leon
says the stupidest stuff when he goes
listen there he'll be like yeah anything
else for me
all those corny one-liners
Legend legendary they're really good but
I mean in terms of action everything
they did now with the parry and the
knife like all of that works so so well
um and I'm playing on hardcore mode so
they cheat crazy they cheat crazy they
got none of that in my life bro this is
the thing if you're an old man and you
want to test where you at
where you used to be what it used to be
yeah bro but it's fun it's fun because
it's Relentless and the game looks so
good it's so smooth I thought some of
the initially I thought some of the
stuff that they left in from the old
version was kind of gonna be a little
bit like just hold it back a little bit
but nah they they polish that out and
that's really really fun to play
um then I went to Jedi Survivor oh and I
Jedi Survivor that shout out to EA for
doing dumb things what happened so they
they share they share the settings
between the Ally and the PC so my PC is
on Epic settings crazy and then when I
go to load it up on the Ally the Ally
doesn't even load up sometimes because
it's like it breaks because it's sharing
these settings
that's literally I literally have to be
when I finish playing on the PC I have
to dump the settings down then log into
my Ally because otherwise it'll just
keep crashing so wait it's a Windows
thing or it's a ea I guess it's in the
EA app that's what allows you to do the
cross do the progression stuff or
whatever so I it's through the EA app
because I got you I got it on Steam but
it makes you initiate the EA yeah yeah
it's probably some type of authenticator
whatever the case may be for whatever
reason is dumb like that and it doesn't
recognize this is a totally different
platform with different specs and it's
like yeah Epic on the Rock Ally
that's crazy that's crazy
about to cut you realize only thing I
hate is I just wish that the EA play
games and correct me if I was I I've
haven't experienced this yet where it's
like the EA play games if I play them on
Xbox yeah that doesn't matter that
whatever my progression when I go to the
PC it's like it's a separate entity yeah
you had that issue go into see that's
the thing go into you have to be logged
into that account it should be cross
progression okay so you do a cross
progression EA play games no but let me
be and be clear yeah I don't have the
Xbox version okay okay that's what I
need to confirm PC to PC I know
everybody else is doing it yeah you can
imagine don't do it I remember having an
issue I think it was
um Mass Effect legendary edition and I
was just like yeah let me continue and
they was acting like yeah this is a
whole different situation over here
because you on PC right now and I'm like
oh I'm not trying to do all this over
Phil so yeah it is what it is but yeah
yeah shout out to Lucius they say now
everything is cross progression between
yeah Dusty so yeah certain things
continue finishing your story with us
and that that was that so yeah I mean
again that game is running it on the
higher settings though the the parrying
stuff of you know pairing lasers and
doing doing all your Jedi stuff it's
really it's finally working well okay um
performance is there yeah
um and then with the ray tracing stuff
on it's really pretty
um and then I did that of course Street
Fighter six that's the forever game
right here I just downloaded it finally
tomorrow getting that getting that can
on oh my God that game that game that
game so we're doing a lot of controls
right
this man get this man out
no this is the thing right modern
controls is good because it allows you
easy access to the most powerful moves
right right and but what it does at what
it does beautifully right from the
person that wants to continue to
progress is that it it shows you that
you don't have access to the setups to
make those moves even more lethal guys
so all this all the smaller the pecking
the oak is at me all that stuff that
sets up those bigger moves isn't there
so you just you're just throwing those
out it's so sad that I don't even play
Fighters and I know what you guys drop
them out of controls is look down on
yeah I don't even play Fighters like I
just see people
say oh I just see people tweeting saying
if I come across people that use modern
controllers you you a bum yeah yo you
see Mighty Kids
that's what he's getting it from he
getting it from mighty Keith yeah
so you gonna be bad Y'all Gonna judge me
before I do this
I wanna
dogs like I want to play in peace
but it's easy to tell anyway because the
moment I see if you can't Peck me or you
can't do any sort of regular movement
and it's just Dragon punches I'm like oh
they hit modern controls I can't do
seven all you kids in a row and yeah
oh man in fact that this is what Street
Fighter 5 was missing Street Fighter 5
had no sort of inroads but if I was
missing everything everything
[Laughter]
so yeah there's this one they really
they brought it back man they brought it
back so yeah enjoy your modern controls
just I'll start usually when y'all tell
me they can I can hide it so they'll do
it
oh like that
anyway that's what it's all that has
been it yes sir and of course we have
the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
access gay back the profit of Xbox Swami
King of the statues who divides nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the whole the line
movement
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir I
am yo
how are we doing oh we do a gun oh yeah
yo shout out to attempt
um shout out to Thor oh man
um
you guys held it down at the sixth
annual uh collector's barbecue yes in
association with dcx yeah
um
when grown men have ice cream truck bro
bro
the fact that y'all had a ice cream
truck literally rented some yes for the
free they came I was like this is the
this was the greatest day ever like the
barbecue and I got this continuous you
this week it's just everything yo it's
everybody clicked up like it's so dope
that car could get there he ain't
sitting with me yeah hug is clicked up
over there
um
they're trying to make sales as well it
wasn't about like they trying to hustle
but it is such a family because when you
know he got me he knew that Surfer
wasn't going to be was going to be that
was gonna be the one because I was you
know I would never do it and then for
them to do the unboxing obviously
shouted Thor and then we put it up in
the net community so I'm part of the
family now they treat me like brothers
you know what I'm saying
statue number two is it's coming it is
kids
and
uh Cog won a statue yesterday yes oh yes
I didn't get some picture of him with
his with his uh trophy that he won
um I won a statue he won a statue and
another friend of ours won a statue
um shout out to the belly dancer aiming
belly dancing she did that she did I
yeah I saw that yesterday I was like
what is going on so I had to put the
family friendly version of her oh that
was the only big I could use I was like
okay this looks awesome I'll put the
video so yeah it's a video go to kick
page if you want more yeah if you want
to see the live video and in some videos
I just could not yes
very talented oh my God she's very very
uh professional professional shout out
to her side pie side hustle in
conjunction with her practice a dentist
yeah I was like right out your mouth
because it's so sweet
um well what I've been playing this week
uh oh well shout out to
I am thinking the team yes
[Music]
unfortunately yes I haven't even opened
the box yet yeah he been busy busy as
hell and yesterday I said I'm gonna get
in I'm gonna do it I got in at 10
o'clock last night yeah well 10 30. um
coming all the way from Jersey yeah we
stayed yeah
it's so much fun so
I've been playing Diablo Diablo this
week yo mm-hmm it has an addiction hook
that is not readily uh um seen on the
surface right and then you start playing
and you start get getting addicted to
the loop of the of the loot you start
going but my thing is my thing is really
the story yes please sir I don't have
any money could you could you please
yeah man here's some bread bro
in the basement my son is choking on
somebody
could you please go down there you get
down there his son is demonic yeah
by the way I didn't mention that he was
locked in the basement then we have a
good side quest of Diablo is wild
wildest oh Lilith that's taking over my
son he's asked about and then you get
set on yes imagine am I said it on you
so
um I'm a necromancer and I run with an
army like I'm running through that's why
I don't be needing people to join me
about my job I got an army of Undead and
I'm like raising them on the ground like
fire so been playing that you know I've
been playing fortnite I'm hunting
his thick character
monkey found her in a different skin oh
check it out and he's dancing that's so
monkey that he would totally do that I'm
like I gotta I gotta buy a monkey
and I love him because he wasn't inside
the store when I got there but I'm
hunting that character
um I saw some new stuff in destiny that
I gotta go check out yes
oh yeah I tried the modern controls yeah
yeah and like I saw upset I'm sitting
there like yo how come I can't set up my
stuff
I'm like yeah it's like you could do
five wow wow wow oh you're getting so I
had it it took me a minute to understand
what I was doing with the modern
controls because I'm used to playing
regular so and I'm like what is going on
here this is weird took it off went back
to my classic controls and
the game just opens up and
first shout out to them for giving you a
visual
like uh like it's it's it's like it's a
feast when you do certain moves in the
splash of the of the of the like the the
world the colors and all that other
stuff are you fighting oh yeah it's such
a big jump from Street Fighter five the
street fighter six because I didn't
think it was gonna be such a big jump
graphically this game is like the Apex
at the Apex of fighting games right now
I cannot wait to see tekken's response
to this right here because usually he's
always Street Fighter versus Tekken and
Mortal Kombat is is is there as well on
a graphical Spectrum this joint right
here is pushing the envelope so yeah
that's all I've been playing
um can't wait till I can uh turn on my
eyes
update listen uh you know the bank is
happy to oblige we love we love you
dearly we love you dearly but for a
moment now I'm just gonna get these
hands for a minute oh oh it's smoke I
want to see fraud alerts in the chat oh
every time oh do anything remotely
portable comes out of my mouth on this
pocket oh you hear
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but when the portable for him around oh
yeah he good he's good good he good he
good and you know what we gotta get
attic smoke too because as soon as he
sees
as soon as my steep deck stop getting in
place and he's like yeah [__] so what
you gonna do with that stuff
I'm willing to try it oh you willing to
try it now I know how to try it since
they had that you know the additional
ones floating around yeah yeah
for some reason I just knew this
handheld was it yeah you did it
I was like yo yeah he was supposed to be
at the event with me yeah he was excited
yo I tried everything in the world today
devil was busy as hell
yeah
but I'm glad you did the thing and I'm
glad it's there ever born hit me up
after ever born in the chat of the wild
uh what I'm gonna call y'all the wild
100s
um because it's like a hundred of y'all
in there and the FTC was going through
their thing and y'all was tweeting I had
to jump out I didn't apologize it's not
that I don't love you guys but I'm
trying to sleep they give you the
play-by-play
ftcy Phil said he's still up this toe
[Music]
anyway yeah but attic you next yeah
I mean listen he's going he's playing
Star for the 60s so he's not happy oh
yeah yeah
anyway and of course we have the gaming
news himself the Shinobi Lord Cognito
spray down really listen to Roman IOP
not telling you what you want to hear
but what you need to hear shout out to
Mr Maddie play Shout out to finally the
Duke talking Xbox's New Direction as far
as where they pushing things with the
the new lineup of game shout out to the
last word he bought just talk about that
Cinema that went down in Destiny finally
explaining things that should have been
explained in light fall but um it's it's
that's actually really good all that did
is make them look even worse you had
this done like you had this like three
months later and you could have showed
it to us and it would have made life a
thousand times better and the fact that
they had to make a statement say because
people are now like all right you did
this dope thing but it's in the season
and historically in the season stuff
seasonal stuff goes away after a while
right so they had to make a statement
that they were like we know you love
this this is never going to go away hey
I was like wow so that was interesting
then yeah there's a lot of spiciness in
the community right now shout out to ask
the cross he has a video out right now
you know we were talking about his video
as well as the other community center I
don't play Destiny as much but I do keep
up with Destiny drama yeah I watched
something something even though
especially Astra girl oh and then Dido
jumped in something happened in the
community I'm trying we all try to
figure out what kind of broke them on
monetization but um yeah and I feel like
the monetization models lately so it's
interesting because usually when this
happens it's because the player base is
down but the player base is very high up
so everyone's concerned is budget gonna
do anything and then the other thing
where it's happening right now solved
that you'll be interested in is that
the PVP Community is feeling like an
abandoned child so they're like oh the
new baby
oh yeah true but it's like even more so
because now Marathon came out Marathon
was like yo we got dedicated services
so check out check out last word we had
to go on me about this tiger Travis talk
about all what's funny we we've been
saying this on last word for for the
longest it's taking the community this
long to get what we were saying this is
last year like yo we feel like
stepchilds or the P it's a PVE game at
this point they don't really update as
much I remember in Destiny one it was
the other way around it was like a PVP
game next to a PVE game yeah PVP we used
to hold down baby enough that's the talk
um yeah as king mentioned shout out to
the dcx or the statue Community um
cookout the annual bro I want to shout
out you know anyone who came up showed
love you know to myself and my Bros and
it was it was really cool to see um
shout out there was somebody I've got a
gentleman's names from some community
that was there who actually knew me I
was just like yo that's crazy shout out
to a Tim brother thank you to love y'all
y'all made me feel like family you know
obviously Thor's the homie and just to
see y'all and to be part of the
community it was super dope I needed
that so shout out to you King I needed
that you know say just to be outside and
you know that Brotherhood yeah yeah I
mean shrimps the shrimps was delicious
the shrimps was the scripts was
delicious everything is salmon it's
everything on that Grill was amazing the
drinks the ah everything it was it was
it was it was too much it was a
celebration it was a celebration
shout out to my boy uh Jose yes you know
he had the bag of treats look at all
these a lot of treats and
extracurriculars a lot of situations
it was definitely things but it was
definitely treats inside the bag shout
out to 108 dragon shout out to ever born
before you've had to be on their podcast
they had like an ally
podcast so that's what was pretty much
been it for me man I've been living on
this device like to the point it's so
good I'll be playing it in front if the
living room in front of I think yeah I
get going I want to test something I
want to play something so for me right
now I did fix a lot of offline issues I
was having so I couldn't get Ghost while
I told you to work before and The Rocker
blade Point fix those so pretty much it
was just um window setting offline mode
as well as there's there's a quick
pop-up that you have to catch when you
launch a game for the first time that
kind of allows it to say hey go on to
offline mode then you never have to
press it again and sometimes the game
will go over that quick pop-up but you
have to go like Windows Task Manager go
to the actual thing and pull it up so
solve that and my new thing right now
solve is um surprisingly
720 120 hertz with rsr on like ghost
wire Destiny because Destiny you can do
1080 60. but the only thing I will say
you know how you gonna test this test
the chin in Destiny go to anything in
Neo Muna in light for any place on Neo
mood because that planet got all this
Cybertron all this stuff oh you're gonna
see what the frame rate do then when you
trying to rock that 1080 60 and I was
like oh he's he's struggling oh he was
he was the last I had the frame rate
count I said oh man what's going on the
Ally was not homily that down so I was
all right all right let me take off the
back State ADP bring the resolution down
at 7 20. because you can play Destiny on
Ally in 1080 60 pretty much every moment
that particular era is the chin Checker
so I'll put it down and then if it's
rocking there um what else I've been
watching you know you know what the rsr
with the rsr if you go into the AMD
settings you can set the percentage of
rsr so I've been and seeing online at
people saying that 70 percent it gives
you that good balance between
performance and and visuals oh okay and
so if you keep it there and you do the
720 rsr 120 hertz and it'll upscale it
to 1080. It's Gonna Run beautifully and
look beautiful yeah because that RSO I'm
sorry okay that's this time the truth
didn't work yeah yeah
definitely yeah I'm sorry the Xbox here
the Xbox Apple PC still needs work Game
Pass
doctor appointment tomorrow so I got a
cataract yesterday yeah
yeah just charge up my baby no doubt I
would definitely get a car charger too
so if I may have to um I need some
settings from you I was gonna say um
Street Fighter six because I just got
out of the demo so that if you got what
settings you got for the Xbox to get
some good 60 plague tale Gallo plague
tail on Game Pass PC game pass okay I
know that game historically is a beast
because even the series Jacks had to run
30 at one point and now they just got a
patch so I'm not expecting 60 with that
or some craziness but I just I don't
feel like I got settings good right now
where it feels I'm comfortable with so
let me know if you mess around with play
Tales or requiem on um on the island
yeah I'll have to download it because
the thing with me is like I said I'm I'm
not getting the extra storage smart this
way it it forces me to finish the games
I put on this bro don't be me don't be
me bro I I'm bouncing around I'm all
over the place oh bro oh Streets of Rage
on this oh yeah of course oh my God in
the nightmare I was doing the nightmare
mode which I never really tried that
your kid won't like that it's amazing
it's like you you and the dojo they're
putting you in these different
situations and then when you beat you
win and be like okay you could pick
either more health or your weapons do
more damage oh that's if you do this you
get more soup and it's like it's like
you gotta keep it oh yeah y'all go love
this mode it's called um it's called
nightmare mode the nightmare mode DLC I
believe it's free just make sure you
install it as an add-on to Streets of
Rage 4. the Streets of Rage forever
still in Game Pass yeah streets are
ready for still in Game Pass okay so
yeah man it's been non-stop for me like
I saw just been rocking and really see
that Street's rage right there yeah
getting my Jane on so yeah it's just so
much to play with and just loving it so
yeah go check that out anyway that's
what I got now um you want to get super
chess we got business what we got I'll
do the business then the Super Chat it's
all business okay let me do the business
let's do the business the first part of
the business
so let's let's do the mic let's put our
heads down ladies and gentlemen give it
a moment
foreign
with the code iron Lords at manscape.com
if my math is correct that's about 16
million balls
now
hi the acorns the coin purse Deez Nuts
the Glizzy companions the Family Jewels
and the giggleberries all of these are
colorful ways of saying balls and for
those of us that have balls we know that
maintaining that area down below can be
a challenge now for me stop me if you've
heard this before I work a lot of damn
hours and that means that sometimes I
come on to this podcast looking like I
jumped out of bed and was immediately
hit by a freight train today not so bad
I'm kind of there now
last week we talked about nose hair
today listen this this has this is the
thing that has to be on on a consistent
basis so now we're back to the area down
below and the area down below once again
after the initial sort of grooming and
scaping shall we say it's time for round
two so the lawnmower 4.0 went down there
did its business everyone in the
household is happy all is well all is
well so if you want to get in on the
performance package 4.0 let me tell you
what it has the performance package 4.0
has arrived and it is a game changer
inside this package you'll find their
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer the crop
preserver ball deodorant the crop
reviver toner the performance boxer
briefs and a travel bag to hold all of
your goodies so first off the lawnmower
4.0 this trimmer is the future of
grooming and then dare I say the
greatest ball trimmer ever yes I have to
concur I have to concur no Nicks no Cuts
it's the greatest their fourth
generation trimmer features a Cutting
Edge ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents thanks to the Advanced Skin
safe technology the lawnmower 4.0 is
waterproof and also has a 4000k LED
spotlight
precise shave because this trimmer is
waterproof you can say goodbye to the
mess on the bathroom floor because of
course you could do it in the shower and
you thought that was good but you want
to take your grooming game even further
to the next level the performance
package 4.0 also includes the weed
whacker nose ear and hair trimmer the
weed whacker is also waterproof and
provides proprietary skin safe
technology which helps reduce Nick snags
and tugs in those delicate nose holes
yes yes you definitely don't want to be
yanking hair out of your nose
that crop preserver ball deodorant and
crop reviver ball toner will change the
way you approach a hygiene routine trust
me when I say this fellas your balls
will thank you manscaped even through in
two free gifts with their performance
package 4.0 the manscape boxers and the
shed travel bag bring your comfort and
boxers to the next level it's time to
take care of yourself so go to
manscape.com and get 20 off plus free
shipping with code iron Lords that's get
20 off and free shipping with the code
iron Lords at manscape.com once again
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code iron Lords
unlock your confidence and always use
the right tools for the job with
manscape
shout out to the fan funding uh sort of
uh
set up here now on on uh oh you're
making it easy for you so you can see
the city I just see everything oh yes no
context for anything it's just all I see
is color now nice nice
757 is here yeah yeah
let's go we gotta save another animal
besides the Platypus we've saved the
planet it's not the Platypus no more
it's the Indonesian groundhog
[Laughter]
hello icon Lords you all enjoying ff16
so far I decided not to get it because
I'm not gonna have time to play it even
if it's more of a character action game
than a jrpg it's really impressing me so
far that's what I heard people like it's
it's a it's a blown out Devil May Cry
but that's that's a great I thought the
SSD is supposed to make the graphics
better
I can't yeah the lie detector detected
that was a lie
I won I won that last week I was like
it's not quite 60.
not quite anything awesome Robert I'll
wait for the PC version Oh Robert Kelly
five dollars in the chat what's better
no 60fps mode but lock 30 FPS or an
option for 60fps but it doesn't run well
and or runs at a very low resolution
do what it's doing
then we have set Lord member for 11
months Lord bronze Order in the Court I
think the FTC lawyers are really
PlayStation lawyers in Disguise they use
the word Sony 81 times and used
customers 11 times wow yeah this is true
we're gonna get into it we're gonna get
it then we have Mandingo big Dickens
remember for two years five dollars I
love the final Foolery 16. especially at
that magnificent 720p on my PS4 he
called it vital food food
yo that's wow
well done by square I love the corridors
and multiple hours of cut scenes King
but
I don't quite understand sarcasm but it
sounds sarcastic
then we have to speak of the devil
Nintendo I knew he was coming remember
for what was I guess he switched back
lord silver 2D Sonic and 2D marrow going
head to head in the same week is great
but we all know the outcome Sega does
what Nintendo and that's loose
for you
he's still he's still in the trenches he
still got his do-rag on
y'all
get those likes up we see 300 that's a
thousand of y'all in here
yeah we did we didn't get the we didn't
get the the likes that we needed last
week yeah play ff16 y'all gotta save the
Hindu rock waller
yeah
Ed ROM five dollars Super Chat listen to
my favorite show while I do work around
the house I told my wife don't You Buck
up on me
no no he ain't tell wifey that you know
if that's the dude that I met and packs
yo
[Laughter]
yo that's why hilarious that's hilarious
and we got some more back slap remember
for 36 months slowing bronze excellent
episode of The Last Word a few days ago
he loving any anything is bad
there you go so he's hilarious you gotta
shout out to slobo here we got big big
mad Mo remember for 35 months Lord
bronze salute to the Lords how about
that negotiation for PlayStation from
the FTC yo but that Indie suicide better
mic drop than the it was a better mic
drop than the whole PlayStation show um
the Indie exclusive Indiana Jones
they was talking it was like yeah man
that's the funny thing right you know
all the gaming reporters were there just
for stuff like that like this yeah
so much then we have Kelly and brown two
dollar super chats stop 720 BS on ff16
that's only performance mode that's the
only mode that matters
oh man they not liking that 7 20 times
my joint don't play in 720.
Microsoft is holding the line against
the FTC yeah this is this is real this
is real drama here dominance Maximus
really yeah he he oh he had them streets
got the suit you got the certainty
shout out to Tim Dog did you see when
they put Phil
the yak is a joint with the with the
font even Phil responded it was laughing
like yo that's wild that ain't they back
then we have Mandingo thinking dude
remember for two years two dollar Super
Chat saw Mandingo also likes easy access
oh
[Music]
I can't beat that you can't be that name
talk about you want access
my wife knows she got worried about
Mandingo too oh baby goes outside with
it
that's my wife you got the burner on oh
yeah she like yo who that
wait did she thought he was the dream
keep your foot on the next dominance Jim
ran crying Jay well it didn't show up
really yeah sealed situations
uh then we have darn thread with the 50
seks sex with the 56. I like your
currency
he's doing the dirty with my girl while
listening to the Lord's hashtag Life is
Beautiful
yo hit that like button I'm glad we
could be of accompaniment
yo hit that like button hit the like
button hit the bad times
then we got Robert killing two dollars
5 was the beta but she bought a six Pam
that is true that is damn true five six
is outside let's go then we got zip
Davis five dollar Super Chat got my hand
stuck in a clogged sink damn like Uncle
Uncle Junior a good thing I had tears to
the kingdom next to me that Vaseline
helped get my hand freedom of the year
for saving me
who wrote that
was zip Davis yo that was wild
disrespectful he said that for four
vastly more performance helped wow
that's crazy that's crazy that's wild
slander for Nintendo
Yelling to the world's authorities how
Xbox hurting them Jim Ryan graduated to
Central Park Karen level pulling the FCC
strings like a dog on the lead you know
we'll talk about it a lot to digest with
that uh hearings yeah we have Nintendo
Taco remember for one month five dollars
what's that it's crazy how the top three
Game of the Year contenders the tears of
the Kingdom Super Mario Wonder Super
Mario RPG I'm back repping the winning
team we got 2023 unlock
last week is done you know okay Boy
Nintendo Direct bro
they're hot they not trying to hear
nothing right now and then let's put the
crust in the chat for the newest member
of the world Lord bronze norm chumsky
and gnome chumsky
salute then we got C dub 813 305 10
stupid chat people that play with modern
controls are the same one they order
non-spicy boneless jerk chicken wings yo
shout out to adding by the way I had to
shut dirt down on Thursday I don't know
what happened what happened what
happened Thursday that that's an attic
show go watch out of here oh
that was smart
every guy's part goes 17 too Brown Super
Chat also pentament is lit the hate was
totally bogus you know
Bible the game
I'm into that heavy thou that should be
that we have the audio Taco uh five
dollars for chat also rest in peace
Spider-Man 2 how you run from Star Road
just to run into the Kingman Mario
Spiderman getting stomped out on October
20th they better move it's true the only
time they tell us that he can't pump
over here
Nintendo came out and was like um
wait who's next to who so spiders
spiders and the brand new Mario today
Mario was on the same day yeah that
wonders game yeah you know what's crazy
too 2D Mario so it's better than 3D
Mario
at 30 miles 3D Mario says Millions
what's up Spiderman in trouble
I didn't know they they put their ass
they waiting for your day Nintendo in
the cut like yeah kill the bees while
he's wounded
line
[Laughter]
they smell they smell blood in the water
your Nintendo said he's wounded yeah
Phil said that feel working behind the
scenes
my light worked Nintendo
Mario deploy
Jeffersonville he said we revealed that
date the defenses have been broken as
soon as he opened his mouth until the
day we got some on Deck
I'm like us an elaborate military plan
is the reason why it's a switch on his
shelf you missed done Sunday that's a
crazy alliance between those two
countries Xbox and Nintendo that's a
crazy Alliance Rick
yo Eddie crew said they deployed married
yo
that's crazy
as well I forgot Jiggy clouds two
dollars
get Paddock the steam deck we need to
convert him yeah we're gonna convert it
out so he can play that Zelda for real
oh my God
60. he'll be done
you know we got support and go 17. two
pounds Super Chat don't be sleeping on
PC emulation it's a godsend yes
scroll down a little bit I am loving
this fast
shout out to YouTube finally updating
features that we've been asking for for
Gears exactly then we have a daddy
passion official official not the
regular one not the regular regular
official the officials
it's my guy two dollar Super Chat let me
make Lord Cog live hold the line
so look we holding it we holding it then
we got a board locked two dollar Super
Chat PlayStation bought Bungie and said
charge them more
that's wild that's wild
there we have Kool-Aid 117 10 super chat
Jimmy boy came through y'all dance move
so far you don't know which side he
moving for don't put his meat on the
stand and that acquisition is in the bag
can't wait for King's take 143 IOP I got
you we gonna get to it we go get to it
and we got c-dub813 once again five
dollars I vouched for that uh I vouch
for that manscape oh well it jumped me
even even here it jumps me hold on a
second that means that we're doing good
I vouched for that manscape been on it
for a couple of years haven't had a
scratch man region since yeah yeah there
you go yeah that's for that's for real
bro Yo's kid you're gonna like this one
this is a messy Bossman says Spider-Man
ran from Starfield right into Mario's
eyes
I bet you Microsoft would have ran from
Mario I bet you he didn't
either way I think it's too late it's
too late
they got new DLC too that's gonna be
crazy the craziest part about it is
Microsoft put the meat on the table and
put start for your Starfield date out
um Nintendo said he said you want some
of me oh man
but that Spider-Man though you looking
kind of sweet
oh man continue
that we see say let's put the crust in
the chapter Cedric H just gifted five
IOP memberships only salute that's love
we got almost 1100 people that y'all hit
that like button 500 likes that's what
I'm saying love that you got them web
shooters B
we don't get out of that over 600 likes
you know Kings Kings friends might not
make an appearance
you was dope we got them locked up we
almost had a thousand likes before the
show was over last week and I made sure
I watched so I don't have to play fun
you barely survived you barely survived
but I got out of there unscathed you
know it's beautiful y'all got them likes
up later but it didn't count then if you
get a thousand likes today I'll play
Final Fantasy and all the stuff
the chat stuff is 30 phrase oh no yeah
yeah that was the talk that was
definitely the time it's interesting how
things change
we running this rap
[Laughter]
we got Tony Bryant member for 33 months
Lord bronze happy to be here live what a
great time to be a gamer yes get these
likes up so we can save the Crenshaw
peregrine falcons
we go with hoods edible hoods animal
hoods wow say shout out to the South
Central Fox what are we doing what are
we doing
what are we doing oh man there we go uh
hashtag holding my hashtag father but I
could just imagine like a nature
documentary talking about the habitat
being
[Laughter]
once again five dollar Super Chat shout
out to Boomstick XL King and C money had
me thinking old school how Phil Spencer
making chess moves like that 94 movie
fresh Sony and say I remember fresh it's
a classic
and we got Necromancer sale five dollar
Super Chat here's some funding for the
Antarctic Komodo dragon
what game is on the top of your must
finish game this the list this year
um well definitely I gotta finish uh
Resident Evil 4 and I want to finish uh
Jedi Survivor but honestly I want to get
back I want to play I have only played
it one time and that's when it first
came out I want to play Alan Wake
remastered because Alan Wake 2 is coming
and I really I Alan way too is looking
bananas bananas I'm excited for that so
that's their own engine too it's crazy
how they they are with epic but they
don't use unreal yeah they don't they
don't they just epic Publishers for them
or they have that that deal whatever but
yeah no we don't want your engine B get
out of here and it really it didn't show
too well at some of games Fest like they
show kind of a boring part but everybody
who saw the game behind the scenes were
like I heard it was nuts Bonkers yeah so
I'm excited for it mm-hmm
and we got a heart get Chinese homie so
I guess Sony hide the FDC to negotiate
their contact with Microsoft for ABK
games at least that's what it seems like
that's what it looks like oh this little
Huggy invite coming brother I mean I got
you all lined up soon to check the deal
then we have Dean Rivera two dollar
Super Chat LOL at ff16 overheating ps5s
yes I got you I got you baby don't worry
about that Lord yeah I told you those
differences you gotta rip the Wings off
that baby yo it's so funny because
during the week when King puts some of
this stuff in our chat I'm like where
are you getting this bro
it has always been some crazy situation
you'll be like how did he find this yes
yes this is this is called real
journalism
October it's going to be the game that
suffers the most you think Island wakes
your boy y'all
um
okay remind me what's an actor we have
Spiderman we have yeah
October Mario
you know what he's absolutely right I
want Alec Wade to have a little moment
to itself and October just got really
really good yeah real we got real okay I
would move uh but we'd like two dollar
Super Chat FTC we are here to protect
our Lord and savior Sony yo yo
then we have pragmatic Eagle member from
43 months Lord gold shout out to ILP
dance moves lying crying not presents
Jim Ryan out here making moves clown
moves for the coaches to eat up thanks
everybody's saying forzas yup I forgot
this is a calculated movie Mirage in
fact over too yeah I would move because
so far we only have one December release
date right to December yeah I'm gonna
put out one game this year he said we
gonna Slaughter it I know they were
trying I know they were trying to hit
that you know that Halloween time
because it's just survival horror or
whatever but you know what I moved that
sucker
then we have Matt Jimenez uh put the
crust in the chat for Matt Jimenez Lord
gold thank you appreciate that
then we had damn I got jumped again
thank y'all yeah you're killing it
showing out today they showing out we
got Highlander oh oh one five dollar
Super Chat Rick Moranis is attorney
character from Ghostbusters 2 was a
better attorney than the FDC
salute flying Jim Ryan did not show
because he is scared
yeah
I saw some of those questions though and
oh you sort of questions I mean the
questions they were asking just like bro
we're talking say the boss I don't know
what I want to say for the topic and we
have sagging nut sacks
he was doing so well is the lawnmower
code available in the UK give it a shot
I'm not sure I would think it is I think
so I think so yeah give it a shot and
you won't never have that problem no
more because being that you're sagging
you know what I'm saying
then we have a stitch member for 43
months Lord gold
came out the closet and finally spoke
the truth he's mad because Microsoft got
money to get everyone a yacht and he
can't have one he's gonna talk about
comments
and we have hard Geeks in the again five
dollar Super Chat from the number of
consoles alone Mario will likely beat
Spider-Man 2. Sony isn't catching any
breaks this year karma coming for lion
Jim Ryan how are they trying to get him
up out of there boy it's gonna be
interesting no PlayStation 6 hashtag
that there you go here you go then we
have a Highlander zero zero one five
dollar Super Chat FTC better pay Sarah
bond for taking them to school this week
will be buyer Hold the Line
we got c-dub813 once again 10 super chat
King about to start tweaking and
twerking on the Rock
we got him we got him got him
look at that I don't know chicken dance
[Laughter]
thank you
he might as well become part of the PC
Master race get the 40 90 and get rid of
that Dusty series X shout out to you all
wow that's the next step
how about the PlayStation first
that's true he will move that one first
before he'll definitely leave
then we have chair Walker member for 24
months Lord bronze Microsoft said to
Nintendo we are giving y'all cars so
send out the Exterminator to take care
of a pest problem
we got a clog in the sink Mario
like he's the finisher
it's gonna be crazy if PlayStation delay
Spider-Man yeah yo I'll put it out for
the PlayStation 4. that word you'll be
crazy if they delay delay out of that
put it on starfield's week
that's the homie always got the cool
videos
then we got Robert kellett five dollar
Super Chat Mario showing up with his bag
of mushrooms and uh flowers acting kids
you want a sample yo we will discuss we
will discuss the wonders of Mario
then we have Autumn 316 welcome to Lord
bronze I believe this is the Lady of the
realm if I'm not mistaken maybe I'm not
I'm not sure but Lord of Lady welcome to
the world thank you so much we
appreciate you
then we got void luck two dollar Super
Chat Mario about to put Spider-Man in
ff16 in the dirt
yeah Mario Mario on the street is what
makes things a little bit different yeah
Mario's outside that definitely is
different they they coming for you boy
yeah it's different they're all caught
up now oh God do you want me to do yes
we got a lot this week we have we have a
lot this week so you said you were doing
yours I'll do mines after yeah I'll do
mines after okay
I will go to my second all right mute
yourself mute yourself exactly let's put
our heads down ladies and gentlemen
all right now
for most of us learning a second
language in high school or college
wasn't exactly a high point in our
academic careers now thanks to Babel the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language whether you'll be traveling
abroad connecting in a deeper way with
family or you just have some free time
Babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons that you'll actually use in the
real world now
a lot of you guys don't know this but
lady SOB is not a native English speaker
she was born and raised in Puerto Rico
and she actually although a lot of
people in Puerto Rico speak English she
actually attended public school which
means that the English sort of
curriculum was not the greatest so when
we got married and she moved to the
states
it was kind of difficult for her
um and as an adult it's learning a
second language is super difficult when
you're a kid they say kids are all
sponges and then they absorb everything
and that's true when you're an adult
it's very hard to absorb a new language
so it was super difficult for her and
she tried everything classes a bunch of
different apps and then eventually came
Babel and with Babel what was great
about it is that she could learn at her
own pace with with lessons that were
created right now so I'm just sort of
generated AI type of thing and then she
she could just do it without the fear of
being sort of feeling like feeling
ridiculed right I don't think she would
be ridiculed but feeling ridiculed in a
setting where she was not necessarily
completely sure of herself when she
spoke right so Babel was great for her
in that regard and she continues to use
it to this day so
Babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go babble's expertly crafted lessons
are built around real life you learn how
to have practical conversations about
travel relationships business and more
other language learning apps use AI for
their lesson plans like I said but Babel
lessons were created by over 100
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective with Babel you can choose from
14 different languages including Spanish
French Italian and German
plus Babel speech recognition technology
helps you to improve your pronunciation
and accent there are so many ways to
learn with Babel in addition to lessons
you can in addition to the lessons you
can access podcasts Games videos stories
and even live classes plus it comes with
a 20-day money-back guarantee so start
your new language learning Journey today
with Babel right now get up to 55 off
your subscription when you go to
babel.com iron Lords that's babel.com
ironlords for up to 55 off your
subscription Babble language for life
be babbling we be badly yeah
apologies because it seems like the BX
is while in today I don't know
yo it's going down by song right now I
can't mute but yeah you could mute now
you did that you did that Spiderman
dudes
in the web shooters beats yeah Luke said
they want to shout us out in different
languages all right all right so shout
out to you shout out to y'all yeah I
didn't go I didn't go to the French
route this time because again this is
important like I said yeah the lady SOB
like imagine an adult coming to into
moving into a situation where it the
language they really haven't had the
need to to use before my wife's a
professional too so it's one of those
things where it's like
her job scenarios are such that she has
to be able to express herself and she
was terrified terrified but she you know
she did her thing she every course that
she could find she did and then when she
got to babble though it was great
because she has it on her phone and she
could do like the pre-canned lessons
that are there already according to her
her level and then on top of that if she
wants more which costs more honestly it
does cost more but you can you can
access live classes and all these other
things conversational things that focus
on just initially the survivability of
it just you talking in in public and
learning how to ask for certain things
and then it graduates you up depending
on what you want too it graduates you up
to like hey
um this is how you speak in a in a work
environment and things of that nature so
it's been super super helpful so okay
get that battle get that Babble you
already know we get these uh we have uh
what you call it the um
poll that we we do have a winner last
explosions spoke in with the Game Pass
showcase now game Xbox game showcase now
completed which of these first party
Xbox game Studio channels are you most
excited for so basic poll no messiness
the winner of the four-way IOP at 42 of
the vote was fable fable has people the
most excited coming in at second place
at 23 of the vote was Clockwork
Revolution
yes which beat out at razor close third
place at 22 was a vow
in last place
surprisingly hell Blade 2 only 11
I think they did that to themselves
because
um yeah you know the way they show them
yeah maybe the waiting sure Lord addict
the people want Fable how you feel about
it
I mean they're right so you know the the
second and third voting they were wrong
and that first one was 100 right I look
like I do think a vowed
kind of like killed some of my
anticipation for from what I've seen I
still you know it's still obsidian
they're still going to make a fantastic
game but like Fable hasn't been around
in so long and people a lot of people
remember that and they have the ability
to re-introduce this game to a newer
audience as well so I I think if they
play their game their cards right Fable
could be that that pillar right up their
gears Halo and Forza that new day quick
question of attic what about how do you
feel about Clockwork Revolution from nxl
being number two over
um a vowed and and a helmet
I think it's just Intrigue like people
are interested I don't think they showed
me enough to make me really want to know
what's going on but they showed me
enough to make me interested on the game
itself no doubt no doubt so we got it
all right so I need to go suckers we're
about to jump into it yeah no doubt
we'll do that um so we'll you'll go next
and yeah I'll go after the final and
then I'll do the final one absolutely so
um we got the um more more there's more
this one
yeah y'all want us to stop this y'all
gotta put more likes hey what's funny is
Daddy goes down
don't worry Sony got that secret super
duper magic killer show that they have
stashed away in their prison purse even
though they gave Keely spidey's date
because they have so much planned oh man
anyway let's get into it all right so
this is gonna be a lot this is my topic
um Microsoft versus the FTC in court you
know we tried I personally have tried to
avoid this stuff but shout out to addict
and you guys say look we got to talk
about this so much stuff that came out
um I'm not gonna go through everything
but what I'm gonna try to do is go over
some key points so things that we
learned perfect yes but I will be
talking for a while so please bear with
me anyway so look uh one of the first
ones is that court court proceedings
reveal Activision Force Xbox into a
better Revenue share for Call of Duty
Sarah Bond testified that uh Bobby kotec
demanded special treatment specifically
a favorable Revenue share and threatened
to pull Call of Duty from Xbox platforms
if Microsoft didn't agree and they
basically said they you know they kind
of acquiesce because they felt that Xbox
players they wanted to keep that their
expectations met they originally only
gave her 80 okay they said they
occasionally do 80 20 Revenue split
which I believe that was asked for
rather than the traditional 70 30 which
they normally give but they felt it was
critical to getting that contact content
number two and they chose the right one
yeah number two an email from
PlayStation CEO Jim Ryan was shared in
court and reported on by IGN um it
showed that Jim was unconcerned about
Microsoft's acquisition of ABK in the
email I believe dated uh January 20th
2022 two days after Microsoft announced
the intent to purchase Activision
Blizzard Ryan's relaxed attitude at the
deal at the time counters his public
facing concern comments since they then
that emerged in a year and a half that
followed so basically
um IGN produced
what is Snitch they just reveal what the
it's called snitching
I don't know why we get IGA okay it's
just I'm just saying okay so Gunner went
out there
all the letters said as far as of what
Ryan wrote in the email is that um it's
not an XBox exclusive exclusivity play
at all so he said that and he said
they're thinking better than that
meaning Xbox they have the cash to make
moves like this I've spent a fair amount
of time with both Phil and Bobby over
the past day I'm pretty sure we would
continue to see Call of Duty on
PlayStation for many years to come we
have some good stuff cooking keep your
eyes peeled I'm not complacent and I'd
rather this hadn't happened but we'll be
okay more than okay so clearly the
statement is a stark contrast the
statements he has made since then and
this was in that email day two Phil
Dominus Maximus are really expensive
it's called to the stand we discussed
that the console Wars are a social
construct doesn't want to count his
community out but that Xbox is in third
place he said Sony is an aggressive
competitor that spends its revenues on
doing things to try and reduce Xbox
Survival on the market he also said Sony
is actively signing third-party games to
skip our platform and that's when he was
questioned over Microsoft acquired
exclusive content then point four Phil
went on to reveal that they acquired
Bethesda after learning that Starfield
might become a PlayStation exclusive
Phil revealed that Sony regularly plays
pays competitors to skip the platform
and Microsoft felt it needed its own
Bethesda to compete to own competition
to people Phil States when we acquire
Cinemax one of the impetus for that is
that Sony had done a deal for death Loop
and ghostwire to pay Bethesda to not
ship those games on Xbox so the discuss
question about Starfield when we heard
that Starfield was potentially also
going to end up skipping Xbox we can't
be in a position as a third place
console where we fall further behind on
our content ownership so we had to
secure content to remain viable in the
business we also learned that Phil is
the decision maker on XBox exclusive
exclusivity also as a result we also
learned bethesda's Indiana Jones will be
exclusive to Xbox so that was another
one uh 0.5 out of all these things I
love everything I said we got six points
but this one was another major bombshell
Phil Spencer swore under oath that
Microsoft won't pull Call of Duty from
PlayStation it's Phil committed to keep
Call of Duty on Playstation to the FTC
loyal multiple times arguing that it
doesn't make Financial sense to pull the
game from solely's platform and it would
harm the Xbox brand if it do if it did
so I would raise my hand he says I would
do whatever it takes he told judge
quarterly in court my commitment is and
my testimony is that we will continue to
ship future versions of Call of Duty on
Sony's PlayStation 5 and he went on
further because I think the lawyer went
on to say hey so you know like just
PlayStation 5 and basically said for any
further iterations of places whatever
happens to these dudes
whatever they happen to turn into if
they happen to be an app
so he went on to stake that game
whatever he's provided that Sony accepts
the deal right that they will continue
to do this if you don't bend the knee
you don't get it B
so you ain't put it put the weight on it
you know I'm saying so um yeah he swung
the oath without looking at any future
terms that need the FTC asked for that
can you swear under oath without without
looking at any future terms that need to
be hashed out you'll ship all versions
of Call of Duty that may exist on all
versions of PlayStation that may exist
in the next 10 years Phil's dominance
Maximus it really expensive says that's
my goal yes so that was huge under oath
and yeah that was an amazing it was way
more stuff but there's a kind of the
major ones that's the gist of it and
yeah a lot to unpack here so any
standouts for y'all this week how we
feeling about all this information let's
start with you Lord addict you know you
brought this to my attention about the
Final Fantasy stuff you brought a lot of
yourself to my attention you actually
payable attention to this stuff to me so
what's going on I can't help it because
people keep tagging me in the stuff on
Twitter like if anything I've seen in
this is uh Sony played themselves you
know PlayStation play themselves they
went out there they were being
aggressive with death Loop and uh ghost
bar Tokyo and my in the moment they
because you know they got the the
appetizers and then they looked at the
main course which was Starfield and it's
uh Xbox and feel like yeah we done we
done and not only because they went and
used those typing you know first off
Xbox has done this We're Not Gonna Act
Like Xbox hasn't done this uh but I've
never seen a company be this aggressive
doing it like shutting entire Publishers
down almost all of their games if you
think about it
there was a time where Sony was going to
get all of bethesda's games pretty much
all the square enix's game pretty much
the majority of both of these Publishers
were going to be exclusive or the
majority of the games were only going to
be on Playstation obviously Square Enix
they've done you know little gains for
you know smaller projects for you know
the Nintendo switch
but
what happens if Microsoft didn't buy
Bethesda yo you know as Elder Scrolls 6
going to be only on Playstation like
what is the difference between
Microsoft coming in and just buying the
studio so that can happen to them and
Playstation say we don't need a body
we're just going to lock down all your
games what's the difference because that
would have been def Loop ghostwire talk
star film exclusive to PlayStation
imagine this year you that's how you
circumvent going to court right you if
you're just buying games the FTC and
everybody else they don't care about it
yeah they don't care about that today
they're doing mergers and stuff like
that see Sony is smart enough to
understand I can just hurt you by taking
away the game I need to own her I can
just get the milk right Microsoft
understood the the the grander scheme
that's why the email says what it says
but go ahead at it yeah and I think that
that's my biggest thing where it's like
look like
regardless what happened Sony brought
this on themselves they they're going
out there being very aggressive and it's
one thing and not only mentioned that
they get in the timed exclusions they're
also locking down missions locking down
content added games you know they did it
with Destiny for years they're doing it
right now with uh they did with Marvel's
Avengers with Spider-Man they're doing
it with uh and then people say well you
know Spider-Man uh that that's their
title they they they have every then why
was it in Midnight Sons why was
Spider-Man on Xbox and midnight Sons so
clearly
they could have been in Marvel Avengers
but Sony stepped in and and made sure it
was only on there well they could keep
that Spider-Man though oh that's that's
Zumba class Zumba class fighting Zumba
Spiderman Xbox with that one
you know because they were so aggressive
and they were you know locking down
whole Publishers Microsoft had to be
more aggressive and you know Microsoft
did this in the 360. they did a I would
say they did a lighter approach than
than PlayStation did in the PS4 you know
they got stuff like Mass Effect Bioshock
they did get a few exclusive content on
their platform but it seems like Sony
locking down whole publishing get arms
like all of them anymore yeah yeah so
it's just like Microsoft was at its
position after the 360 where they saw
this happen and they're like we're not
going to go back and do that again
because what's going to happen
is we're going to pull up Bethesda
snatch star field we're going to pull up
to Activision snatch a couple years of
marketing for Call of Duty and snatch
maybe the next Crash Bandicoot and then
what's gonna happen they're gonna be
like oh well we don't want to work with
you on Elder Scrolls six you know the
the price of the brick went up it was a
match success so it's just like
terminology PlayStation X PlayStation
put Xbox in a situation where
we got all this money in the bank do we
really want to deal with other people
that own the IPS that we work with do we
really want to have another cryotic
situation well we gotta negotiate with
them on who owns rides yeah no we're not
doing that so they just bought the whole
company because PlayStation's being
aggressive like that the consequence is
what now they're not getting star filled
they're not getting Indiana Jones right
but guess what if PlayStation bought
these companies no one would even
question
you very interesting you know very in it
and it's just like as far as like the
Final Fantasy stuff they Phil Spencer
pretty much came out there openly and
said you know they paid to have 16 not
on Xbox
yeah which I got it's just like one of
the I understand that everyone is guilty
for this
but I've never seen companies snatch
entire companies games all of them
because if you really think about it
they they didn't get redfall because
that probably wasn't enough in
development where they see a clear
picture of what it was going to be at
the time imagine if they didn't buy
Bethesda yeah they were in trouble no
star filled this year going to be
exclusive to PlayStation on top of no
star field yeah it's just like look like
PlayStation just has such a dominant
effect on the industry that the only way
to truly compete and people say oh they
could keep making great games they can
but at the end of the day
Google try to pop in and snatch a bunch
of stuff didn't work out for them
they're doing Amazon's doing like Luna
right now you know and I get that's not
traditional console making it is not
easy to compete with a company like
PlayStation and Nintendo or Waverly
Brown going at you he said he said but
it's a good thing when Xbox buys old
Publishers that's right it is because
it's the same thing
look the only difference is one wrote a
bigger check than the other well one
that's the only thing y'all wanted them
to compete right shut up
don't want them to compete but y'all
don't want the deal to go through now we
want to compete let's compete let us
compete you want us to you want us to do
better right
let's do better don't don't sit there if
you want it
don't sit there and say oh no you know
Microsoft y'all should not do no do not
be opposed to it be for it so you just
when the company that that owns like war
or frame and all of them when they were
bought guess who's one of the bidders
king
PlayStation we heard Bethesda was a they
were bidding on Bethesda we heard they
were bidding on Warner Brothers it seems
like the only the only person you should
blame is Sony for losing the bids they
ain't got the money
that's like going to the strip club with
a bunch of honey
and you win a thousand dollar section
was looking like me
they put in an eBay bid y'all
it's like at the end of the day
PlayStation's been bidding on all of
these companies they just keep getting
outbid by all the trillion dollars we've
already refuted organic once Bungie was
was purchased that kind of destroyed all
that it comes down to it's like you know
people say well PlayStation's not
worried about Xbox doing then why do
they keep bidding on the same damn
companies but Xbox is bidding on because
they know what's going on here it's not
a coincidence that they never really you
know uh grew their company to this
degree to a Xbox started dropping
billion here Billy in there and buying
all these companies because Sony has
always feared Microsoft in this area but
Microsoft has never put this kind of
money into the industry and now that
they are doing it Sony has happened to
escalate their stuff okay you know
insomnia
who says a place if Microsoft never
would have bought those companies in
2018 would they have bought uh insomnia
games it's debatable they wouldn't if
they would have kept working with them
close by and never actually committing
and fully buying the company that's why
it irritates me when people sit there
and they act like Sony's not scared of
the Landscaping of the business uh I
guess what a king it's it's in Sony
working their way towards a cloud
disputing type of uh technology aren't
they doing that yeah well you know you
know imitation is a sincere
let's get this little fake console thing
they gonna put out let's drum up some
business over here for our cloud service
for this PlayStation 5 that seems to be
lacking
Jim knows what's up um I'll get to it
let me finish
we got 1400 almost 1500 people here oh
let's go listen listen man come on now
we need to save the Bronx snake
just the regular snake in a Bronx
the reason I was late coming into this
you know it wasn't because I was playing
Final Fantasy 16 I'll tell you that
right now oh okay it's because I was too
busy locking up King [__] wow
we we we have this key it's called a
thousand likes and that that comes
undone oh wow it has been locked into
the best
you can't come out okay I I have
myself built the key oh wow
Supernatural season five yeah that's
what I did wow and until that gets to a
thousand likes he's staying there
you're on an interesting line of a
thought process with this whole saudi's
movement I was gonna ask you like so in
your opinion based on the way Sony was
moving with locking I said all these
exclusive we found out about Starfield
you know do you feel they were because
right now the talk is we're doing this
whole thing because we're worried about
the fcc's doing this whole thing because
we're worried about harming competition
right competition you know that this
deal would harm the scope do you feel
that if this deal I mean didn't happen
if somebody was allowed to do all that
you know um software purchases and so on
and so forth but exclusive that they
were on a mission to harm Xbox or to get
them out of there because that's what
I'm saying some of the talk as well do
you agree with that are you saying that
as much as hyperbole
I feel like PlayStations I'm gonna do
what PlayStation does best you know they
they compete when they see Microsoft
stepping up their competition
they can't do what Microsoft does let's
keep that 100 you know they could buy
Square Enix they could buy companies
like that but the difference is it's
easier it's like I said multiple times
it's easier to convince your board
members to drop eight billion dollars
when you got 50 million 50 billion in
cash Sony could easily get the money to
buy a corporation like that they could
they could raise billions of dollars
they have plenty of assets they could
use that against it but the problem is
is it's a huge risk to ask your board
members yo let me let me uh let me spend
like 30 percent of what our whole damn
company's work let me spend 30 percent
and go buy this hopefully it will work
out for the best so what do they do the
next best thing okay Microsoft go out
there they can throw out that money and
be buying all these companies we're
gonna strategically plant
games where we see fit and I feel like
you know it started with the Final
Fantasy 7 remake yeah they saw success
there then they're okay let's see what
else we can do you know we can't buy
Bethesda but we can snatch death Loop
right we can snatch Ghost Squad Tokyo
and then we could stat star Phil and
Microsoft heard that because I think
Microsoft
before if they never would have
approached them for a star foot I don't
think Microsoft would have for Bob
Bethesda because I I think that when it
was just Square Enix Microsoft was like
that's a Japanese company helping a
fellow Japanese company with business
they've worked in the past right it
makes perfect sense but then when Sony
crosses the path
after that hold up hold up hold up hold
on okay okay
you can stand your projects looking at
your girls but when you come across that
street to my projects
I was like Hey Ma he's like nah B get up
out of here
and that that's why I feel uh when we
heard star film might be exclusive to
PlayStation they're like look even if
it's just one game two games three games
we're talking years of development that
one game is equivalent to three years of
making three to five years of making
that okay by the time that studio gets
around to making almost if not almost
the engine generation is gonna be over
we're gonna be in the next Generation
keep in mind star throw took like five
years to make so by the time their next
game comes out we're going to be in the
next generation and with one investment
Sony could have snatched that whole
generation of that game yeah all we know
Starfield could be the next great thing
the next game of the decade in Microsoft
and Sony was willing to take the risk to
try to make those an exclusive now Sony
don't have really the the free money to
go in there and just be dropping money
and stats in the whole company I think
that would probably be more up to it now
because Microsoft's doing it but I do
think part of them's like this publisher
things over you know even if Microsoft
buys Activision I think at the back of
their head Microsoft's never gonna try
this again but I feel like if Microsoft
comes out at the with the w at the end
of this Activision deal Sony and
Microsoft no we're probably not gonna do
this
I get where you're going with it they're
not gonna go and get like um what's that
uh embracing group right they won't do
that but they're going to embrace them
but like remember the stuff I asked you
to hold
that over here oh you'll say good you
know how we do yeah let's go so little
things like that say and then one Sega
separates they sell from those pachinko
machines and all that other stuff
they're already separated yeah this is
what I'm talking about they already got
themselves prettied up right they ready
for the wedding
her hand her nails you're getting her
eyebrows done the lashes
and Microsoft just want to do this
and the last thing I'll say before I
hand it off to so I've got to get his
boss
I don't know who this went out see
the best thing that came out of this is
Indiana Jones hell yeah because you know
what's crazy you know what's crazy if
you really sit there and you think about
it if you really think about it and now
that we know this game because even
myself I was told it was an exclusive
but even I was told by a person I trust
but I said you full of it because I was
convinced this game was a multi-play and
the fact that they had this in the
chamber and never shot it publicly yeah
it's crazy they could have easily
Imagine This
open up last uh the the next episode
three or whatever it is has an Indiana
Jones amazing Gameplay at the end it
says XBox exclusive the the the stadium
would have would have went crazy
look we got to get some of his balls
he's been very patient oh I was so happy
when it was like it's exclusive
we got about 280 or buck don't get out
oh man they're almost dead they're
almost there oh yeah 280. well no okay
I'm it's like close to 300 likes we need
from you guys or I'm Gonna Keep Buck
locked up I don't care buck up that or
not but I'm gonna keep him locked up
holding characters
that's some PlayStation stuff
making content exclusive Lord addicts
that book is
I'll block it I'll team down man
this guy here anyway Lord solved lots to
unpack tons of Bombshells news where you
at with this whole situation how you
feel about some of this information
that's come out I think you know we've
been talking about this for so long now
that what a lot of people aren't really
addressing is the finality of what's
Happening Here Right One Way or Another
Something's Gonna Go Down finally right
maybe next week or maybe next week right
as soon as next week right so the
finality of it is what makes it
interesting because now all the cards
are on the table all the dirt is getting
slung and and when you see it see this
is the thing right
we're all looking at the proceedings and
the things that we're hearing how stupid
some of these questions are that they're
asking and it feels like it's the blind
leading the blind and when you think
about the the the court system in the
United States there's a lot of that that
happens on every level whether it be
something like this on the corporate
level or whether it be on the on the
ground level with you know somebody
going to jail for x amount of time for
something they didn't do because of
incompetence uh so my thing is listening
to all these arguments right and in the
back of my mind also thinking that it
might be a political agenda behind this
I'm just like I don't know I I really
don't know if it the obvious thing that
we're seeing right is going to come to
pass and the right thing is going to
happen which is the injunction should
not pass because the the arguments are
weak right the arguments are just weak
and for no other reason other than the
arguments are just weak but I just don't
have faith in the system of course that
is going to happen right so I'm just
like I'm looking at this and I'm like
okay I know that micros they're not dumb
you know they have a plan B a plan C a
plan whatever if this doesn't go through
right and it's any number of different
permutations of the things that we've
been talking about where you break off
Call of Duty or you buy this you know
again uh you haven't Embrace a holding
on to the home
King King
yeah no you're absolutely right so um I
just I do it's interesting and it's kind
of exciting because there's going to be
finality to this and I don't know that
it's gonna go the way that we think it's
going to go based on based on just
politics based on just politics and the
fact that we're looking at it as Gamers
and people understand and and talk about
the industry and we know that these
arguments seem stupid and bogus but it
doesn't matter if there's an agenda if
there's an agenda it's not gonna matter
right so that ultimately is the most
interesting I think when look looking at
the specific stuff that's come out
um the stuff that like made me raise
eyebrows which was really the Bobby
codic stuff
the strong arming and and again Xbox put
themselves in this position right with
the Xbox one they did right they they
had this relationship before during the
360 generation it did not have that
leverage anymore in the Xbox one
generation so I get it but to the point
where it's weird that Bobby rotick would
be like hey this thing that it that that
does numbers everywhere nah you need to
give me this much money for me to even
think about putting it on your platform
yep and and that is that and also you
have to pay that much money which the
other guys aren't paying yeah right and
you can't talk about it on your platform
as if it's going to your platform until
x amount of time you got the marketing
rights and they strong it's like that
was the if think about gangster that was
that's that's a guy bro that's just
official king that's a where we from
that's a stick it's like yo what you
gonna do you know it's like you go in
the store the dude like okay let's say
you brought to Arizona yeah so Sony goes
in and Buys in Arizona for 99 cents you
go in there and put your Arizona on the
counter and they do say about 50.
and you said what I'm thirsty it's hot
outside he just paid it out I don't care
what he paid you shut up and you give me
the buck 50 and then you get out my
store yeah so either you drink or you go
yeah what you're going you got to pay
the bucket yeah you're thirsty You Got
No Label on Arizona your logo ain't
nowhere near it they don't promote it
Broad
side Brown was like yeah we bent the
knee yes we bent the knee because they
figured they say yeah they could not to
to Delight their customers right they
knew the importance of having Call of
Duty on the platform for them to not
have and the fact like you said so think
about the bluff that's called let's just
say like Microsoft didn't want to do it
think about how gangster you got to be
as activist to be like so what if they
say no yeah that's kind of crazy dude
you ain't on a lot of stuff yeah you'll
just be another one
and then they turn around like you don't
even we don't sell on your platform
anyway we don't care like it you know
it's it's mud slinging back and forth
right
um but again business prevailed and the
right business move was to bend the knee
even though they were being strong arm
um so just that the whole idea when you
think about all of that right and then
for the dime to turn completely be like
yeah we're on the same side you think
about the relationship right yeah that's
an existed relationship so you think
about the how how frivolous and and and
that business dealings are like you
could you could be enemies quote-unquote
enemies and if and if the number's right
that's all gone because they just got to
it a little bit different
um when I get to when what I don't want
to jump okay it's a little bit different
I I believe I have a different theory on
that yeah my only thing I was going to
jump in was just that you know now that
you fast forward then it's like oh so
you're going out of business huh my ex
about to come around oh hard times now I
aren't moving those arizonas Iced Teas
like you used to do oh look like you
need to be saved right so it's
interesting how business could change
things but continue yourself you cook it
you cook it and it's just like just
looking at all this other stuff it one
it puts Microsoft in a position where
this does go through
they're kind of almost obligated to put
a whole bunch of games they probably
weren't going to put on other platforms
on other platforms right they kind of
have to live up to at least some of that
stuff so they have to make decisions
around that uh if this does go through
what's going to happen now if it doesn't
go through and through you know whatever
whatever sort of different permutations
of of this deal or other deals go down
now they're not beholding to anything
right unless they they get taken into
litigation again and now they could put
everything on just on Xbox and Game Pass
or whatever and not worry about it
whereas this deal going through in this
form
I'm not saying it handcuffs them because
it just it gives them more money right
but it does sort of lessen the impact of
oh these are Xbox games in the Xbox
ecosystem right it does give more
Credence to that whole thing where Xbox
is going to be everywhere and again they
have to be fine with it because in order
for this to go through they have to be
fine with that
um so to me beyond all that it's just
when I look at all the little the all
the little points about you know
Starfield potentially going to be
another like exclusive to PlayStation
the fact they haven't decided on the the
you know the the other the outer worlds
too and they haven't decided on Elder
Scrolls exactly what's going to happen
there right it ain't going over there or
they have to say that right they have to
say that um the fact that like the thing
about it is that that's obvious to me is
that it put on the table all the safety
dealings of the entire industry like to
addicts Point everybody's at fault for
it because everybody does it that was
the business model that has been the
business model now
my thing is if you're going if this
litigation is going to force real change
in the industry so that everybody can be
uh they can really they can they can
really allow true competition because
let's be fair
there wasn't competition before because
the way Sony was operating they were
operating from a position of strength in
that they know because of the popularity
of the platform these they can make
these deals a lot more easily than Xbox
code it's just a fact so whether they
earn that or not that's fine but that
was an advantage yes all across the
board that they've always had it's never
been a fair playing Ground in that
regard because again as we've said
Microsoft always nine times out of ten
came in with a bigger bag and the answer
was no right
so for me everything in front of me
tells me this is a no-go this is a no-go
this should be shut down there should be
no injunction and then things should get
interesting but I do not trust the
system politics baby I don't trust the
system I think it's going to be a very
very messy messy week or two weeks
um and I'm I'm just I'm here for the
ride you got into the 29th okay and
that's the thing right because
they themselves said it right and this
is the thing of the finality of it right
if they if they do get this injunction
and they can't close the deal before
that that initial date right so that
deal is dead now yes they can go
renegotiate right and they have been I
have heard and I know yeah I don't know
if you mentioned this [__] but they have
heard that if they if they're able to
block this deal and the deal ultimately
falls apart that three billion dollars
that is supposed to come out of
Microsoft's pocket there will be
litigation to try to get the FTC to pay
that
this is an exciting time because if this
deal goes through as is it's it's a it's
a it's a shift complete shift in how
we've seen the industry until now if it
doesn't the things the subsequent things
that are going to happen as a result of
it not happening will also cause a
seismic shift in the industry so no
matter what things in two years will not
look the way they look right now and
that's that's scary and interesting and
I'm here for it I'm here for it no doubt
shout out to everybody cop in I see them
copy them hold the line shirts I see
some IOP shirts being cops Lord King
very interesting read those super chats
because we have some serious yeah
and I want everybody to be heard before
I even say a word right now
we got 1400 people here yeah they out
here they're showing out they're showing
enough time to to get Buck out pause
that by the time I talk then Buck ain't
gonna show up
okay I see what we do
some stuff no I got the key so it's like
it's up to me if he comes out and I
demand a thousand likes if you want Buck
hold the line and defeat bug about 823
likes y'all 1400 in the chat might show
up for Final Fantasy if y'all don't get
him out right now for the FTC he might
show up for Final Fantasy let's go go
open up YouTube on your on your phone on
your mama's phone
hey babe could you hit the like button
on iot walk into your siblings room
right now stop them from watching
whatever they watch say I need you right
now to go like iron Lord podcasts we
need a thousand likes man we got to get
buck up in the realm who's but don't
worry about that let's go like the
channel it needs to come out man
all right cool almost like gonna be
jumped and okay we have Aramaic lvt five
dollar Super Chat this FTC case is more
entertaining than season one of Game of
Thrones bro
yeah yeah stocking up on more popcorn
for Thursday have a great weekend Lord
you as well brother appreciate it Luke
we got c-dub813 with a hundred dollar
Super Chat thank you appreciate that
much love lessons I've done a few
Consulting projects with both Sony and
Microsoft the past 15 years the deal
will be done but nothing will change in
the scope of gaming oh all right we got
the inside all right I can guarantee if
and when the deal gets done it will it
will be on the PlayStation Plus and Game
Pass if Microsoft releases it on Game
Pass so there's a question that
Microsoft released Call of Duty on Game
Pass no so he's saying if the deal goes
through he thinks that it's gonna also
be they'll be allowed to have it on uh
on a piece of places
we almost had 900 likes come on
oh
then we got Tom from Toonami five
dollars we chat the FTC case died the
second the judge told the FTC lawyer to
shut up and sit down yo I'm gonna I will
address that the judge is outside she
said learn your place and dismiss Phil
off the stand question the question King
is Buck gonna address that because this
is
some time time on attic payroll and IOP
I'm trying to give him time I'm trying
to get him come on we gotta drive by Joe
oh it's my stock that's my hitter these
companies accepted the monies companies
know Xbox don't sell games PlayStation
didn't need to throw much money at them
just enough to cover the Xbox half
so what's it 100 likes back to back back
to back two get back then we got slow mo
back slap remember for two years five
dollars we chat if 10 cent didn't double
Sony's bid new Warframe content in their
next game Soul frame would definitely be
play PlayStation and PC only that is for
sure then we got Tom from Toonami again
five dollars Sony could learn from
Admiral Yamamoto I fear all we have done
is to awaken a sleeping giant and fill
him with a terrible resolve yeah we know
what happened after Pearl Harbor
not good the Dodge Knight s oh what's
the Hobie the homie what up Lords can't
wait for this ABK Saga to be over have a
blessed day all of you you as well guys
see little dinky dogs I see Dodge
outside that's what's up that's my guy
then we got bigger from 14 20 Super Chat
the wildest part of the FDC
cross-examination with Phil was the FTC
essentially negotiating for Sony it
tried so hard to get Phil to commit to
having all ABK games come to PlayStation
essentially in perpetuity
a lot of stuff we talked about there
Indiana Jones then we got c-dub8 13 10
super chat to add context I meant if
Call of Duty was launched on Game Pass
it will also be on PS plus extra premium
yesterday they they said as much right
the vote was like we'll put it on I
don't care this is the underlining
purpose of this trial I know this for
sure the other games no so it's still
the Call of Duty still the focus yeah
okay hold on let me get back to the
other one drop box
okay pick Afroman 14 once again 10 super
chat funny things from the FTC hearing
Phil having explained console Wars and
Phil having to explain if switch is Gen
9. still having to explain how an
acquisition Works to them yeah that was
crazy yeah like hi this is how you buy a
house this is what it means you know
some dudes in there was renting they
don't know what Equity means exactly
your rental yeah we got Robert Keller
throughout the super chat if Sony
lockdown Bethesda two it's over and
that's the thing they would have locked
they would have locked it down and could
you imagine the relationship continues
what would have happened with Elder
Scroll for sure because they were
targeting all of it but that's just big
IPS do you know what's happened to it
now exactly exactly
Indiana Indiana Jones
we need over a little over 50 likes
we need to hurry up
we go Mr orange ten dollar Super Chat
Lords Mr orange
blessings Jimmy B dancing two dollar
Super Chat 200 More We Get Buck Hold the
Line let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go and we got heartbeat city five
dollars to protect with you Sam as Hogue
has been saying you can't account for
crazy hope things go correctly over the
next few weeks with the with the with
the hearing hashtag Hold the Line let's
see yeah exactly hold it CWA 13 again
the thing is yes it's been said it will
be on both services but the deal will be
more than 10 Years it'll be indefinite
that's why Sony turned down the 10-year
deal then we have metal Macias five
dollar Super Chat timeline Bobby what's
his name
he think he's slick yo five dollars in
the chat timeline Bobby threatens the
full car from Xbox MS uh infiltrates
activism with two topics X abuse Scandal
is exposed activists in stock tanks
Microsoft box
they sent in the hitters for me so we
found rap pool in the back of your store
oh man
hit that like button
we are nine away
now I like the studio
get your key for your hat ready
the ball is about to drop three more
about to get Buck Don't You Buck up on
me oh we got it 1006.
all right now go get changed I'm sorry I
couldn't read the last one but now I see
clearly we have Ricardo is literally now
the rain is gone Ricardo is Islam I can
see
five dollars dgc look like old testament
King James peach seed demon much love to
the guys
salute to the realm yo they made
salute the attic for his hustling
let's get
let's get him ready
oh man
I told you what a little dollar could do
a little persuasion
oh man so quick question Buck how was it
how did it feel to be locked up in
attic's case I didn't like it at all
[Laughter]
I knew
he told me to make you watch that that
hearing over and over again well you
know
technically how I see it it's business
baby
just busy doing business now I paid the
right lawyers
to negotiate on my behalf you know 10
years that's inadequate I want a
lifetime but [__] you you've been caught
on camera saying that you weren't
worried about the dude okay
oh okay that wasn't you we we had to rip
Mansion I told Jim Don't You Buck up on
me
it just seemed very contradictory to to
what was yeah I understand I told Jim
about sending internal emails to
external people
you don't know what cc means
no you have to talk we we had a real
talk with Jim oh okay we got to sit him
down that's why he didn't show up is
that is that why he went from not caring
about this deal to caring about this
deal
that's why he didn't show up he had to
send a videotape Jim ain't in the best
of shape today
we had to take him out to the shed
because he was bucking up
and I said Jim did you send that email
yeah I did is that your CC right there
is that IGN oh man you send that to IGN
now you know IGN is
[Music]
I told you
yeah one job and you did it wrong
because you know you spend a lot of
money in the PlayStation ecosystem and
you know now that these Court
proceedings are going on like a Phil
taking the stand and everything you know
where's your mindset with how this case
is going to go I'm just curious oh these
boxes going okay I'm just curious
we gonna get to what's really going on
are we gonna kill him
all right so first of all
we're gonna act like this hasn't been
Sony's ammo
they did that with Final Fantasy in the
beginning of Nintendo
remember Final Fantasy 7 was supposed to
be on Nintendo
they swooped in purchased
on our platform
this is the DNA the DNA is to lock off
games from other competing platforms to
hinder their progress
they made inroads
on Nintendo's ground
they made Sega disappear by doing these
same practices so when I see people say
disingenuous stuff like Microsoft needs
to compete
either your level of ignorance is at an
all-time high or you choose to to fake
ignorance
right because it's it's okay when it's
when it's in your favor you're not
screaming out nah man that's not fair
man let the game let Final Fantasy come
out on Xbox and let's see you know who's
who and what's what no you Champion it
when it's on your platform right
but you want competition you I want
Microsoft to do better
this is fake concern fake it's
fraughtery it's the highest degree
that's your favorite kid I understand
that you just don't want to see your
favorite kid get whooped so the big kid
come in the yard and you make sure you
tie one in his hands and then you tie
his shoes together
so the big kid can't really fight now
now
shout out to Phil Dominus Maximus are
really expensive hit the stand
I'm gonna say this this is the
difference between
The Tale of Three CEOs Bobby a real G
yeah Bobby let me let me explain why
Bobby I'm not I'm not supporting
anything Bobby has done inside I'm
talking about
as a position
you you heard Jim said I spent for the
last couple of days significant time
with Phil and Bobby yes
Phil's going into the situation
knowing see Phil's calculating Phil's
going into the situation let's talk
let's see if we can mediate this well
there was a snake in the Mist man
this is this is why I told y'all from
the beginning Jim is good for y'all
y'all like that stuff y'all over there
y'all like this backstabbing you know
conniving
swindling doing he he does that he's a
swindler
y'all don't know why Jamaican gym never
showed up again right oh yeah
because certain people can't handle
certain smoke and it hurts certain
people's feelings
you know so y'all can make all the
little memes about Phil
take it don't say nothing
Phil take it I do Jamaican gym somebody
cries
it's true that did happen we gotta stop
that we gotta stop there because it's
hurting somebody's feelings that did
happen that is fast yeah all right so no
Jamaican gym so that's why Buck is here
so that's why I let y'all know Buck is
not Jim all right I don't want you
crying I want Buck to disappear
so they sitting there and he sends out
an email
telling them
now you know it's a bigger play they
they got bigger goals so Phil telling
them now this is the play to stand in
third we we gonna give you all that you
knew from the jump that y'all was
getting Call of Duty
you knew from the jump you were getting
it um
but you say you know what
I'ma stop this
I'm gonna go straight to Brazil
and I'm they trying to take Call of Duty
away you went to every country help me
please they're trying to set us down
these Deuces out here actively trying to
get they brought xenomax man
anyway if they buy APK man we're done
and you were doing this you went all
over so disingenuous good shout out to
IGM oh my God I love you the email
without you guys this war could not be
won
oh my God but we getting politics now
getting how did
someone
do that here but y'all do that then and
there's still more sealed information oh
yes
Jim's deposition saw was supposed to be
already out and some stuff is still
sealed it's supposed to be more
information that doesn't come out
interesting exactly so shout out to you
making an appearance you made front row
appearances to every country in your
frequent flyer miles is bananas
but you couldn't make it to the FTC here
you said the videotape yo they said that
it was so critical PlayStation wouldn't
exist but at the moment of the case
which is the yeah I'm not going in there
shout out to the real geez yes this is
the difference
I want all my hood dudes this is hood
dude stuff I'm talking to her dude this
ten toes down this is okay yeah I'm
talking to her dude all right let's go
take it stop rapping them rats
this this is real stuff you saw Phil
come on there suited up the whole Squad
Satya Phil Sarah oh Matt booty everybody
front and center this is our face this
is what matters this is what's up and we
taking a stand what's what's up
we I never want to say this but yeah
that dude over there he'd be doing this
that side stuff
so he forced me into a position where I
had to go buy things I could have did it
before I tried to play nice with old boy
and then it comes out you went over
there to play nice and you told them nah
it'll be there
they had a private meeting with you
letting you know reassuring you that it
was all good in your email you say now
we gonna get that we gonna be good we
got god of war and all that we're good
yeah
even woke up and was like we ain't good
at all
these dudes are spitting to take the
hell over
um I'm so proud
that when I got a chance to meet Phil
because I see all of y'all now all y'all
now oh Phil's a real G
they back on they back on there yeah you
know yo I'm
now oh yo now I see Godfather pictures
you cools uh oh you feel walking like a
buzz Crown all of a sudden now your job
can feel shout out to me Tim was rapping
food no no Tim has always been there
yeah
I just I just want to say real recognize
real and I knew when I saw Jimmy wasn't
real I knew it from the rip yeah but
then I also knew the dudes that was back
in that dudes and y'all wasn't real yeah
I want the deal to go through and it's
going to go through
it's going to go through when the judge
tells the FTC lawyer sit down and shut
up hit him with the wrap it up B
no she said I'm tired she falling asleep
when you talking
she said I just listen it'll feel answer
this question are you gonna put Call of
Duty on a joint under oath you say yeah
for as long as they exist
that's that's real Baltimore Bible got
worried that Christ's roof I testify
under oh brother that died
for as long as you exist in any form
that you dare to be
it ain't gonna be a PlayStation 6 after
that this is the rise of dolphins y'all
y'all are watching it y'all did it to
yourself and I'm so happy you did if
y'all wasn't so greedy it wouldn't go
down like this y'all went for Starfield
you reach you reach for the stars I
literally and they had to smack your
hand down enough
Stop Being Greedy
Max hours now shout out to this this is
our gangster
Microsoft is this procedence is going
through Indiana Jones exclusive
we don't care what y'all saying you're
not getting it it's done here
and as we go forward and you know it's
funny king that's the second game
Microsoft popped up and was like oh we
just don't want you to make a
PlayStation version like cancel that
that's good at the beginning of the dark
field though no it's it's
when you go and sit down me and you go
break bread we have a conversation
factual and and the after me and you
leave we shake hands over the eye bro
yeah we good and then for me to find out
you flew to Brazil
like after we we sat down we broke bread
you you in Brazil talking about I'm
harming you
like what what's the allegation he said
what I thought this was consensual what
you said what
Nabi that's not how you rot so
you put the and and he stopped answering
Bobby kotec phone
you you got to look at the Timeline so
Bobby Phil and Jim was all in agreement
you stop answering the phone when Bobby
say yo man what's up man what you doing
you know the bag was in play what's
going on here he said just you said it
wasn't even a body school we told you
what it was about what's going on with
you
left one thing
that snake moves
so what happened you think the Judge
don't see through this you don't think
the world don't see through this they
see through everything that y'all doing
and where's Final Fantasy 16.
y'all are giving them ammo to say they
are keeping these things off our
platform so the only way for us to
compete is to actually buy these
companies in order to compete because
they will go behind and lock off these
games with this practices that they're
doing
the deal is going to go through it's
going to go through on the 29th fall
they're going to go through the
deliberations and they're probably like
July 1st or something like that or
whatever that Monday is but they're
going to close arguments on Friday
you know it don't look good for you when
you're leading
sends a videotape
so he can't be cross-examined he can't
answer those tough questions because he
ain't built like that because they would
ask him yo so what happened y'all had
y'all had a conversation you feel and
Bobby what was in that conversation
I'm down to see this tape what is the
deposition something like that that's a
tape yeah
he's gonna tell his side of the story
but he's not there to be cross-examined
that's a cow would be yeah bro like
those coward moves I can't rep so
anytime y'all see me repping feeling
you're like yeah you rapping how you
gonna call a man dominance he's showing
you
he's showing you actions speak louder
than words you know he's there you
understand
so
all you PlayStation dudes now talking
about now this deal ain't gonna go
through but I thought you won a
competition so why wouldn't you let it
go through oh damn King is awesome right
now why wouldn't you let it go to you
you won competition right you want us to
fight right right so let it go through
you're good anyway right you got God of
War right you got all these games you
got Spiderman right oh man yeah you got
you got Grand tourism y'all make bangers
quality stuff right
in third place with nothing why are you
fearing us why are you snitching on us
we don't what it is King is they want
Microsoft to compete on PlayStation's
terms yeah but see the difference is we
don't care about that
we don't care about your terms we got
that Meme that says we don't care that
that dude that's like on ESPN yeah we
don't care shout out to Phil being who
he is the person I knew he is and when
this deal go through and we pop bottles
you can directly
that is the right man at the right time
in the right position doing the right
things
and when y'all become third place
that's a pit you will never climb out of
it you know what I just realized that
people put that boot on your neck
something that you've never seen
they got the equity they got the caster
Jim told y'all in the email
they have the money to do these things
yeah that that week that that deal is
yeah it either gets passed or it doesn't
get passed it's gonna be very very good
for king or the best rolling we've ever
seen cases
are you good kid you're good yeah I'm
good because
it's going how I said it was going to go
and the judge shout out for the judge
son working at Microsoft
talk about that
she ain't got a vested interest
solve are you are a little bit more um
because you you you're like me like we
feel yeah I forgot to uh uh you're the
one that said it I'm sorry I'm sorry but
you said it it looks like you got to
stream Final Fantasy 16 too because you
said that thousand you was gonna play
with you
shout out shout out to see I know along
the lines somebody gonna get a promotion
and you know what that's how you play
the game because
if we're gonna call out her son working
for Microsoft let's call out the FTC
lawyer who used to work for Sony factual
factual shout out to him politics
negotiation on Sony's behalf to make
sure that they get these games in
perpetuity throughout the Futures yeah
the rumor is that he was a key decision
maker on why I got blocked that's your
politics rule yeah yeah it is because he
used to work there he got favors and
they got dirt they got videos they got
real video this is a real video he don't
want to come out so um
Gangsta Gangsta the Bible has words that
Christ will evil men sacrifice group I
speak on my life under oath that was
Boss by now I salute the journey through
the life yeah man Phil was on it uh I'll
just make mines fairly quick look
FTC seemed very unprepared I just got to
be honest like
the line of questioning not
understanding how Windows works not
understanding how an acquisition Works
still with this weird Obsession of the
Nintendo switch classification of a
console being competing King the part
that was so wild to me
how you call stadia as your star witness
to defend you and stadia says that
messes up their whole argument that
cloud is a market of its own it was like
nah I could piece for console gaming
it's it's in the like that to me was
crazy that was your incident oh you call
up this dude to defend you and he
talking about cloud in faith of of
Microsoft's argument that was crazy
that's dope I'm with song you know what
I'm saying politics going politic at the
end of the day I've thrown out logic and
reason with this case I've thought out
what's actually fair for consumers
notice consumers don't get mentioned a
lot with a lot of this questioning so I
already know where this was at from the
beginning that's why I'm kind of where
I've been with King where it's like if I
had to pick if who going to politic more
or at the end of the day Microsoft I
knew they're gonna fight all the way to
the end with this one right so I'm okay
I'm standing on it that most likely it's
going to go through I will think that's
interesting is the judge seems Fed Up
um they've been you know the constant
look I get it from a Sony perspective
you're gonna protect the bag you're
gonna block the deal no matter what
you're gonna hate to the end right I I
get that but the FTC is looking
unfamiliar to me like your job is to
protect consumers
they seem hellbent on protecting a
market leader
okay
I I I I'm gonna disagree okay go for it
go for it the FTC is looking very
familiar they lost like didn't they lose
the last 10 cases yeah they lost mad
cases when they come in yeah yeah so but
yeah
okay that's what you're saying they have
a losing record if you was a fighter
right
nobody to back you so I can't back you
because and it shows how ill-prepared
you are for a situation and picking
fights that you have no business picking
but this is collusion at its finest
because Sony the FTC and the CMA have
all colluded together and I cannot wait
for those emails to come out we're going
to see I mean I think to me the by the
way I jumped a bunch of codes in the
chat oh that's what's up for me the
biggest red flag for me personally
is we got the multiple questions to fill
under oath are you sure you know 10
years how long just PlayStation 5 no no
future and where the judge is like bro
we've answered the question already how
many times you're gonna keep asking the
same question multiple times let's move
on but the thing that wrote raised the
red flag to me y'all was when they were
like so what about Diablo you gonna give
us the album we're gonna give like when
you're the lawyer negotiating for Sony
to get a better deal
that seemed insane to me that's just me
from the outside I've never seen that
like that I could understand your
Microsoft should start hiring these
people for their competition all the
time
in the beginning here the joke the judge
said in the beginning no no you got
three Microsoft lawyers and two ABK
lawyers that's probably soon to be five
Microsoft that's crazy look it's just
it's different it's different
um we'll see how this thing goes uh next
week uh what is it Satya takes the stand
yeah Bobby
and Bobby was gangster with it he got to
go Bobby got to go so we already know
Bobby ain't got no kids in the world
Bobby told Microsoft today
right everybody
so if you read that gangster dude ain't
gonna go on there and be like nah these
dudes right here lion B they sat here
and when they didn't give out his emails
when he when he give out the recordings
boy you think Bobby got Bobby got the
skeletons I think it'll be funny you'll
be funny if Bobby goes on Stan yeah we
did increase the price of the brick on
Xbox the PlayStation
no I think Bobby is a wild card if he go
up there and be like Sony told me to do
it
I've been doing all this [__] for a long
time yo oh I gotta break protocol on top
until I said Bobby about to be Sammy the
bull on his stick
Robbie is about to turn States
we got to put Bob yeah we got to put Bob
with your PC after this right now Bobby
got security yeah yeah here with you all
around him I can't wait that's the day
when y'all gonna really see it all go
down because Bobby telling you right
Bobby's gonna lose the most it's a fact
let me address the the chat real quick I
apologize guys you know uh when it comes
to like restricted areas of codes it's
really hard to mess around you can ask
solve we've had to deal with it the
entire time we've given stuff away yeah
uh if you live in an area that those
clothes don't work for I apologize but
it's not a whole lot we could do about
it yes yes it's gonna be the VPN
yeah it's crazy it's crazy but yeah
that's pretty much what I got on it
we'll see hopefully next Thursday they
look like they're trying to wrap this
thing up and the last thing I'll say is
that we'll learn more solve because next
week after
um young Odin's idea after Bob Eagles
understand during this time the judge is
going to get to ask questions and when
to me when the judge asks questions then
we learn in my opinion which way that is
a definitive thing but which way they
leaning what the judge gets something
like okay I'm confused you you work for
PlayStation
if the judge says okay if this deal goes
through
oh you're gonna give them Final Fantasy
yo you stupid I just want to know well
Microsoft finally get Final Fantasy 7
because it said it was supposed to go
there yeah I've seen a lot of pictures I
got a bunch of DMs I need to know what
Final Fantasy 16 is going to show up on
the Xbox platform and if they be like
nah all right deals done
yeah yo shout out the heck to F yeah
said the FTC lawyer negotiating for Sony
should could be seen as an act of
treason for a forward entity negotiator
I was shocked about that Diablo question
I'll be honest yeah and and the people
were like making it like some stuff it's
not it's like no it's like the FTC
in all sense is for competition in the
states
we'll see what happens like how how is
Japan and every other entity outside of
America gonna approve this and then when
they go on the stand the ftc's talking
about PlayStation the competition no
other one just mainly PlayStation's best
things that could happen to them unless
that lawyer is a Microsoft plant right
I need you to go in there and say this
because
listen politics going politic we'll see
what happens next week but look let's
move on super chats and then on we got
the next topic which is attic super
chats are crazy you guys are doing so
much today yes
yeah I would say so super chassis and
then you do your business yes and then
all right give me a second okay we got
c-dub a 13 50 Super Chat thank you bro
but King Dubai and stream that Final
Fantasy 16. yes that that is happening
oh yeah and you could stream yeah here's
the thing when it comes to these
normally we always stream them to the
the channel but we are do redoing how
our Channel functions this reason like R
and R left yeah so most likely they'll
be streamed to the twitch Channel
let me see that we got my name is mud
remember for two months Lord gold buck
buck cluck cluck cluck
that with you on the way down y'all
y'all was part of that group
let's play with each other
five dollar Super Chat I heard we
getting buck
I don't care unless I'm getting the butt
naked with salt yo wait he said that
yo
we have 1100 lights
I don't care unless I'm getting buck
naked with song
yo please buck up on me
oh yo yo we got to put time on you on
that one that was a wild pause that was
wild let's just turned to an unrated
[__] yeah wow we getting shut down you
got to send me those pictures of me
eating that Sonic ice cream oh yes yes
yeah yeah cause these dudes is like
y'all ain't you ain't no Sonic
the whole truck the most childish stuff
I got SpongeBob I got Sonic there we go
Spartan six six one five dollars the FTC
has less brains than a woodpecker on an
aluminum telephone oh man
then we got homemade media two dollars
Super Chat Sony knees was hurting in the
courtroom yo CW says soft you need to
get a restraining
you gotta Auto protection
oh man we gotta really surround him when
we go at these yeah we got to protect
some of it all costs rubbing up on us
off
tsws gaming but for two but shout out to
you brother two dollars which that attic
gonna go put water in Bucks nasty food
dish
there we go I I
says you can buy and do whatever you
want with your IPS instead of Hold the
Line we going to run you over with the
line that'd be crazy as hell oh man
never got the ever born Saga yes it was
just business till my girl games only
the business
there we got Spartan goes 17 five pounds
Super Chat Phil getting active in these
streets pulling in the low rider blowing
knees with his Mac tens ten toes down
how y'all think this will affect Jim's
image Jim don't care about his own
camera yeah
snitch I'm gonna wreck I'm gonna say
videotapes I'm gonna send him wild
emails I don't know what a cc the bbcc
let's send this out right here everybody
this one this one is hilarious y'all
baby 505 he said Jim Ryan is Rico from
belly
in the banana like I don't like this one
I don't like this I'm about to drop a
dime on them niggles
[Music]
wait what was that what was that Luke
then we got spark trying to go 17 two
pound Super Chat Jim main Built For This
Saint with the chassis not about that
not about that and we got Tom from
Toonami two dollars Super Chat Bobby
about to be Savvy the bull on a stick
that's crazy
there we go Filipino Beast five dollar
Super Chat can you imagine a judge's son
just dropping pieces of paper on the
benefits of the deal as hints when the
judge is making her decision
he over there like nah they they did for
the people man
[Music]
I don't like price increases but for
years we all said we feel like that like
we're stealing we knew it was due for an
increase cop online codes and be easy
we'll get to it next time we got Misfit
God five dollar Super Chat FTC stand for
after competition yo that's crazy all
right then we have hold on a second
that we got Joe Dunmore two dollar Super
Chat the FTC just want that overtime
money they're just trying to to milk
I've been saying that from the beginning
it's certain ways that you can get to
the bag so much money is out there
everybody wanna peace biggest way for
you to jerk wreck is to extend time
you have money in overtime everybody
getting paid there yeah what Microsoft
yeah you could lose that back
then we got Robert Kelly to get two
dollar Super Chat lady SOB needs to get
that double barrel ready
yeah
we got a little better Troy two dollars
from chat wow a Nintendo topic the world
must be at us now Nintendo did their
thing bro
and we got Nintendo Taco five dollar
Super Chat what you guys are stance on
the controversial statements by your boy
Randall Thor made on the Xbox two on
Friday I might have to cancel y'all too
yeah that was crazy they coming for me
they call him uh Bland outdoor because
he don't put no seasoning on his chicken
he'll like no like some place yeah they
coming for the kid like no seasoning
when you cook it or no condiments okay
first of all
y'all gotta look at what's the only
white dude I know that's that's never
put nothing on there but his dietary uh
yeah
yeah you can't judge somebody's diet son
he just like he don't like that but we
we confirm he does put ketchup on bro
he's not as bad as he bought it so he
bought this
he said we do can we can confirm
be good
then we got y'all baby father two
dollars to protect I jumped the gun but
I'm I'm in traffic on the BQE oh he's
the BQE oh salute yeah be careful out
there be careful out there we got hargit
to me remember for 23 months Lord go
putting them codes in the chat for the
family for the realm got a street
fighter 6 Global code and an re-4 remake
Global code as well thank you thank you
love thank you brother give a shout out
to Heart Geet if you got those codes yes
these are they well I'm assuming their
PC codes but um it could be expensive
um then we've got Nintendo Taco two
dollar Super Chat he said he don't
season his food not even so yeah another
Xbox goes PC codes aren't that long yeah
yeah I think epic might be that long
actually
good yeah we're good we're good yeah
it's time for some sweet talk oh yeah
gotta get sweet with it today's episode
of eye Lords podcast is sponsored by
PayPal how study the easy way to save
When shopping on your iPhone or computer
did you know it only takes a few seconds
to get it that means if you go add it to
your laptop or iPhone right now you
could be done before this ad read is
even over how does getting something
done super quickly make you feel what's
great about checking an item off your
to-do list really fast you know what
else really works fast honey sweet talk
dealing finding abilities honey is the
free shopping tool that Scholars the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one it finds to your cart here's
how it works Lords imagine you're
shopping one of your favorite sites when
you check out the honey button honey
button appears and all you have to do is
Click apply coupons wait a few seconds
as honey searches for coupons they can
find for that site if honey finds a
working coupon you'll watch the prices
drop you know cog's all about his
handhelds you know I got my rug Ally and
honey recently saved me money on
accessories for my Ally I was all about
getting that ten dollars off by power
bank when honey notified me on checkout
in my browser and it was extremely easy
to use did you know honey doesn't just
work on desktop it works on iPhone just
activate it on Safari on your phone and
save on the go so Lord so I need you to
do getting honey seriously only takes a
few seconds and by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a solid and supporting
this show get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com
iron Lords that's joinhoney.com slash
Iron Lords so go get that honey y'all
you know what I'm saying you do talking
sweet talk report we're talking seeds
then you want some season on your deals
man
if I know anything about Cog he bought
plenty of assessors oh yeah bro I got my
power bag I got the dock bro I was on my
session as soon as I went to check what
I like as soon as you go to checkout is
scours it's cool it could be you get 30
percent it tells you all the codes you
can get I gotta do that when I go um for
because you know I need that doc yeah
and then the power bank thing I'm
listening to y'all guys I'm hearing is a
benefit to coming last pause
to actually you know more ways than one
oh yeah
oh my God
here's the thing I know you know we've
been picking up like the sponsored posts
and stuff it's it's required for the
podcast to go forward but I haven't
really seen a lot of you complain about
it
really appreciate it because like in
order it's pretty Next Level we gotta
need that money to advertise and stuff
man and where do you think it's coming
we try to make it as entertaining for
you as possible we have our own little
uh oh you know our personalities
y'all most of y'all been there all day
ones and like addict said you know they
understand the growth of seeing our
trajectory what we're trying to do so we
appreciate y'all for rocking and if
you're new uh please subscribe you know
share it out share it to a friend no
doubt no doubles with the algorithm all
right yeah one more Super Chat real
quick before we move on yeah baby chat I
be copping the other honey from Ock
yo yo yo yo yo yo that one in the PayPal
one can't go wrong
you're different this is different and
you know when it comes to the stuff we
sponsor too you know we we we do think
that you know uh you guys will enjoy
especially the honey stuff like why
would you not download honey that's my
question
my Chrome I'm loving it and you're gonna
need it when you buy that 40 90 for the
head oh yeah yeah I've seen some people
with that that's kind of crazy yo
somebody said y'all got that my honey
pack yo I'm done anyway
Mario Zelda and Sonic taking out Sony
titles yeah it's gonna be you'll be
something
okay all right good you sure did we get
um you got your you got your baby father
right you got it okay all right the good
thing about that separate Windows now
it's hard to miss stuff I'm not used to
stop being like so old quick like that
like you don't have this is perfect it's
so perfect I love this yeah
yeah he was doing
what they only see in color nice what
what they I I want to point out because
I saw a lot of people saying that I cap
when I say I play like I've played like
the older final fantasies I don't know
why you would think that but you know
what it is what it is on that see ya you
know I I I'm a chef something here
second so keep going all right so look
this is actually your topic you want me
to set it up or you good as far as the
uh yeah you can set it up all right Xbox
raising prices out in these streets
Microsoft is hiking the price of Game
Pass and the series X so this has come
out shout out to The Verge shout out to
them the legend every time Warren so I
just paraphraged paraphrase um series X
price will remain the same in the U.S
and match PlayStation 5 pricing in most
other markets game pass prices are also
going up in most markets so you know
they've alluded this that Microsoft is
increasing the series X in most
countries in August apart from U.S Japan
Chile Brazil and Colombia so those kind
of staying the same and that um the also
the Game Pass Game Pass and Game Pass
ultimate subscription for the first time
next month would you see a base Game
Pass subscription uh moving up from 10
front to from 9.99 to 10.99 so basically
a dollar there and uh this was kind of
the communications
yes kick a dollar
oh look at you I know what you're doing
um so this is from Kerry Perez the head
of Communications on Xbox we've held our
prices for consoles for many years and
have adjusted the prices to reflect the
competitive conditions in each market
and then the series X console going in
the moving in the UK okay from 400
479.99 pound uh to 549.99 across most
European markets Canada from 649.99 and
um Australia I believe that's
799.99 and Austria starting August 1st
so um Series S price will not be
adjusted in any markets which is
interesting and um Game Pass ultimate
pricing that will increase will start
from uh July 6th and that will move from
the 14.99 to
16.99. so yeah those
like no they were coming at me hardcore
you wouldn't be yeah I have all the
summons I even have titus's Ultimate
Weapon and I try to scroll up for Lee uh
Lionheart so get off me get off because
anybody coming out here
everyone's level 100.
and it's like I said I have all the GFS
all of them in eight Who coming in
why are you having to prove yourself
you're not the one that anybody's been
coming out about finishing games
so you know that that's because all it
was is I was I was I was making
statements about 16. and people didn't
like that so they're like
check your resume only hits you with the
resume chat yeah and what's funny is
like it's just like nah just just take
that L walk home because trust me it
doesn't end there I can bring up other
Final Fantasy we know how you get down
bro you're in the attic for a reason
they need to walk away from him yeah
that's not a fight that's not a fight
you one lady young boy alone yeah yeah
young boy young boy's a shooter he will
get you out of this so um he know life
game exactly
and in real life he big don't mess with
him
because I look small next time
beef
moving on to the topic
it's beefy
get your beefy hands I like to eat I
like to eat
oh baby
he walked through the cookout
Vader like Cognito has entered the baby
[Laughter]
me
well I
lies look out
Lord Metro with the two dollars
moving on moving on
Bessie
I'm gonna really get these people here
attic let's go continue
the price range I I actually think this
is a huge mistake on uh Xbox's part
especially with the momentum that they
had with that last showing look does
this kill all that momentum no but uh to
me it's like you know you finally got
some good publicity a lot of people are
talking about you in a positive light
you should have pushed this and you know
you determined that prize to that series
X when you started your marketing for
this and you shouldn't have went back on
it I don't care what happens you don't
see too many companies ever doing this
just raising prices mid generation uh
this is this is not right and they
should feel ashamed of themself but at
the same time
what what can I do you know I I will say
that
it's the same thing I said with the
PlayStation
the people that aren't in America should
feel even worse because they literally
like the because in the majority of the
countries this was raised but America
and like maybe another a couple regions
like they literally just looked at
everyone else who said you know
we need the prices here to be
competitive with PlayStation and because
PlayStation raised the prices in these
other regions we could compete with them
by raising our prices and I don't think
that was the goal you know being the 50
difference would have really helped you
in terms of you know once you start
getting these games out and I get it
starfield's coming out soon
so their mindset is this is probably
going to be the best game we've had for
a minute and we're going to really try
to Captivate that but to me we just came
off redfall this is the time where you
lower prices not raise them this is the
time where you make more value to your
platform not make less value in raising
the cost of Game Pass made more sense
but that console is where I draw the
line that shouldn't have happened fair
enough addict has spoken saw with the
twisty face yeah chat about what's going
on Solve IT disagree with it with the
face
you know what it is it's just like
sometimes I really feel like humans
don't look at some of these like
scenarios and it's just a computer that
they input numbers into be like oh what
should we do now it's like like you know
that you know that person we all know
that like can't take a compliment yes
like when you compliment them and they
like insult you yeah they can't take
they can't they can't take a w and just
walk away
and it's just again it's not huge it's
not momentum shifting anything like that
it's just is an unnecessary mini rake to
step on right like why do I do this yeah
don't don't do this don't especially
again
listen The Game Pass increases we knew
were coming this is Starfield tax people
tax you want the games you're gonna get
the games down the bangers are coming
right the bag isn't coming you're gonna
get Forza you can get Starfield
everything that that's in the pipeline
seems like it is of that quality with
this is not Crackdown three we're
talking we're not talking about
this is Justified now especially I did
mine so I knew that was coming
shouldn't you know they have announced
this prior or or maybe you'll wait a
little bit long sure but whatever the
Game Pass increases and those are across
the board so everybody paying the
Starfield tax right everybody's paying
that so that's fine but the console
stuff is egregious and it was it was
egregious when meta did it it was
ingredients when PlayStation did it and
it's agreed just now when they're doing
it uh you can't it's it's hard to
justify paying more money I don't care
what region you're in for a piece of
Hardware that is nearly three years old
it just doesn't make a whole lot of
sense it doesn't make any sense
it is the numbers will tell you
differently but at the same time you
cannot tell me that part for part some
parts of these not maybe not all but
some parts of these machines are now
cheaper to find and thus should be
cheaper to build right now I understand
inflation across the board is ridiculous
you have to sort of match but to me if
you're kind of quote losing the
PlayStation in these other regions where
you're now matching them
I think it would behoove you to be below
their price point right it just makes
sense so in that regard the business
reality supersede sort of what the what
what it looks like right the the sort of
uh perception
so whatever man it's it's not a huge L
but It ultimately is an L I don't think
they needed to take right now you know
for me it just doesn't make a whole lot
of sense when it comes to the hardware
again the hardware that's the Big L
because for me no way no way you're
telling me to pay more money for
something now than that when it launched
nearly three years ago
yeah the game pass you knew it was
coming the timing is whatever but it the
game path for me it is funny but that is
stuff okay
I'm sorry I'm I'm chat I'm done with it
I I'm going out and I'm buying stuff for
this wall because I'm tired of people
saying this is the only fans angle and
what it is it's the white wall it's the
white wall that's what it is it's the
white wall we're done with that okay
this Banner's coming off and I'm putting
actual stuff back there because I'm done
with that that's like the eighth time
I've seen that what's funny is I because
I used to have uh like a portable like
my camera's on like a portable Mount and
I remember when people we're making fun
of it I put it beside my bed on purpose
and took a picture
maybe that's what it is I think maybe
they just want the bed pick oh
they want to take one because they heard
that you sleep with the door open yeah
time the door unlocked in the window oh
I remember that Super Chat moving on
moving on yeah
I forgot about that I didn't need to be
reminded I didn't need that visual
moving okay beefy
listen I'm scared though beefy I like to
eat I stand on it you ain't gonna you
ain't gonna body shave me I like beef I
like to eat okay okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
how are we feeling the price I'm chunky
yesterday's price is not today's price
kick How You Gonna defend this right
defending it oh I'm not defending it at
all all y'all guys that was talking
about y'all got game pass for a dollar
give me that dollar back give me that
dollar back Beach y'all thought y'all
was getting away with it yeah man I got
game pass for a dollar it's up now give
me that dollar
all y'all campus yeah Game Pass is worth
a dollar I Gotta Give me that dollar
I'm not I don't I don't like that yeah
um don't tell me is inflation it's
impossible because you're raising the
price of the X but not the S so you know
that makes your argument but the answer
remember they did the right thing with
the S which is they give you a new SKU
so they can keep it at that price and an
older skill I wonder if they're gonna
discontinue they're gonna discontinue
that one so you think you think little
man is out of there the white I think
the white man is out there I think a
little white man is gone yeah we're
going to replace little white bear a
little black man I think I think I think
they upgraded them and changed with the
bigger package
we're gonna have to change our little
man
right now our little man is not racially
sensitive you know what we should do we
should have little white man and little
black man and put them back put them
back yeah we don't have to do none of
this you don't have to do that
[Music]
I could be fans of y'all all I want
but wrong is wrong factual and you're
not doing it in in the sense that you're
doing it where there's no competition
and those markets that y'all are leading
in y'all raising the price
I said that to Sony Sony did that
the markets that they lead it in they
raised the price they didn't do that
over here this competition here we need
reasoning we're gonna keep that in this
in this States it's tough over here
hard out here
y'all didn't need to do this
and if y'all really want to stand on
that square I know Starfield is coming I
know y'all fitting to have the best year
in a long time
and y'all had a great show I think
you're too high in your supply I think
somebody over there that decided to say
yo it looks uh wrong if our series X is
cheaper than a PlayStation 5 because it
makes it seem inferior Whoever has that
mindset over there and don't have the
mindset at sellout premium at a loss
under what they're selling it for so we
can gain more traction
that person needs to go oh damn because
financially
you're doing yourself a disservice so
you walk into the store listen y'all
still number three y'all ain't jump
overnight okay y'all walking somebody
walks in the store
and Playstation has their lineup up
there start filling out yeah bro and and
maybe that dude don't even know about
Starfield let's really think about it if
somebody goes in there and like yo we
got Starfield and this is the Casual
well they got Spider-Man
casually I know who bought Spider-Man he
climbing the walls he shoots what's your
style filter yeah well you're going to
space and you got ships and you can
fight and you can make ships I sound
like Glock let me get that stuff that's
a Spiderman
y'all the same price
you got to give incentive you got to
give incentive to purchase you're not
that recognizable y'all keep acting like
you're famous you're not but what about
this let me let me let me be corporate
[__] for a bit go ahead so like what
about this King like all right I don't
like corporate I like coffee
you stupid that was good that was good
so like let's just say like all right to
your point right they shouldn't do that
whatever but we heard right part of the
EU negotiations with ABK was that they
were concerned that once Call of Duty
coming to the service
now the price could keep going and part
of negotiation was to lock that price in
right at that time so now what if they
like yo if we don't do it now we can't
raise Game Pass or whatever ever for the
game pass like what do you feel about
things they try to beat it while the
before the day this is inevitable
because you're gonna have the family
plan this this is preemptive right you
do this have everybody have all this
outrage oh man they're raising the
prices at the family plan
right it's the same thing they do
something else to mitigate the bad news
right they do because they're going to
take a loss with the family plan yeah so
let's lock in these single you know
player people like Sovereign
and then when we get the family plan and
iron Lords is on a family
it's different but
they do that now because they know
they're gonna take a loss with the
family plan let's just you know isolate
the the single players and and do that
um I just don't like it I don't like
anything that is anti-consuming this
smells anti-consumer to me uh nothing in
it uh screams that you know we're in the
biggest depression recession that we've
ever been in as a a country as as a
species for me at my time this is the
worst it's ever been and for you to just
say yo we're going to raise it up 50 I
already got my ex I already got my S
I'm fighting for the dude that didn't
the dude that was getting his his
panties up trying to get it together so
you walking into the the room you you
got your 500 left I got my five yes 50
more
ah man no well we got a little man over
there that's the same price and we got a
little black man for fifty dollars it's
like yo it's just it's wrong it's not
right you shouldn't do it I'm not with
y'all on this and it's not about
inflation it's about actually inflating
your wallets they don't care about y'all
this shows that they don't care because
if you can you would say I'm not gonna
raise it raise game pass because I
thought Game Pass was always the
greatest value at the cheapest price is
what the best deals right so yeah a
dollar two dollars yeah it's it's it's
it's really not about the the the small
amount that is being raised y'all gonna
get that dollar back I always knew that
he was gonna get that dollar back I
always knew that they was not giving you
nothing for free nobody do right once
they lock you into those numbers
stabilize once they saw those numbers
yeah okay we got 30 million and stable
same 30 million we had last month same
30 me get our dollar back
you like it they like it they like it
back so
what do you feel about the argument
that's saying but addicts they aren't
raising PC game pass they're only
raising console camera because there's
competition over there I was going to
touch that too it's competition over
their attic anywhere that is real
competition at they not raising the
price so where there's no competition
and they're probably dominating in that
sector or they they're close to being
like number one if not number two
they're gonna raise the price because
they can't it's just doing something
because you can
is there competition because there's
multiple storefront those are
competition because there's multiple
subscription models because I would
argue that
the store fronts a little bit more of an
argument over there on PC but the
subscription model the majority of the
subscription models are on consoles as
well right so it's just like it are they
seeing more of a growth on PC or are
they seeing you know there's more people
on on Xbox currently and they're trying
to milk those and then eventually
they'll milk the app that goes into a
bigger argument as The Wider PC dudes
don't have to pay for uh Xbox Live
that's why I bring that up because we
got to the point where it's not only
do they not have to pay for PC online
they don't have to do anything for to
access the internet well we shouldn't
have to right but they're also not
getting increases on on subscriptions
that console owners are getting caught
they're getting their raise and remember
there was a time because it was in beta
you paid half yeah for the PC game pass
when they didn't do that on Console when
they were starting that up but the thing
is that that is an open market PC is an
open market Xbox console is an isolated
uh situation so they know when you go
buy an Xbox you're locked in you have no
other choice but when you buy a PC you
have so many options to do so many
different things let's just get them in
any way we can I think to me
business-wise I can understand why they
do it but as a consumer
uh it's like look if if you feel like
you're still growing the audience on PC
you wait till you feel comfortable
raising on both you don't just raise it
on one and keep it on the other like I
don't like that I'm gonna be real with
you I don't like that I feel like that
is another example that could be used
against that uh against the narrative
that they treat console own owners like
second-class citizens compared to PC on
PC you are placed on PC you have PC
exclusive content over there that's true
you you have you don't have to pay for
gold you don't get right you don't get
raises on PC Gamepad you can make a huge
credible argument that they are pushing
you into the PC market well I mean I
believe everybody's going that way
anyway I believe the PlayStation was
going that way I believe Xbox is going
that way Nintendo probably won't but I
believe that's where they will
ultimately end up that PC is the
ultimate um It's The End Game
I believe that's it I believe
everybody's going to be an app I I just
believe you're going to grab your
controller and play where you want to
play how you want to play it and um if
you have a dongle or if your TV supports
it if your tablet supports it I just
believe both of them is going to get
there who gets there first depends on
this ABK deal because ABK deal goes
through Sony's gonna be the first app
Eastwood in the chat Xbox needs to get
rid of gold ASAP yeah they got to figure
that part out that's later yeah yeah
because it's just one of those things
where it's like look like does it bother
me specifically no I don't really care
to be honest it bothers the hell out of
me but I understand why people get upset
over it and it's frustrating because the
biggest thing that bothers me is if a
game can function on Console it just
takes a little bit more time like gears
tactics or um uh the Age of Empire games
because those eventually did come to the
console Market you hold that to you can
release simultaneously on all your
platforms you don't do it over there
because you want to appeal to that
audience if you wanted to put that
audience you would keep it just on that
audience but clearly you have the
intentions on bringing it over here
eventually don't do this release here
over a little bit because then it makes
me think that's a that's a window I can
open okay now we're gonna have mobile
games on like it's just like so now
there's mobile games only and PC games
only but no console games only and it
just sits wrong with me as because I
don't play on PC like that but it it
does put a bitter taste in my mouth
that's like why is everyone getting
everything but the console manufacturers
uh that the people that go out there and
we invest more if you want to get
technical we go out and spend the 500 on
the platform
yeah you can make an argument that we
are we baby boy baby boy we we try
everything first and the biggest reason
I'm like being very vocal about this
because I know a lot of Xbox people
watch this and it's just like
when is it when's the line because I
personally feel like we've crossed the
line
oh my God because to me it's like
where's the line because I personally
feel like we have crossed the line you
know we holding it
[Music]
yeah I'm fantastic yeah now look um I'm
with y'all like no one should be
cheering on price hikes though it should
be pumping a fists like yes this is what
it is you know even if the even if our
Market is unaffected right in the US so
to speak as far as the um the console
but um look you know we gotta we gotta
give you know what's the same energy as
the kids say you got to get the same
energy you know we gave PlayStation that
energy when they did it we didn't really
care for that and you know usually like
soft said as the generation goes on from
a console perspective you think they
figure out ways to bring price and cost
down consoles get smaller you eventually
get you know cheaper skus and you know
it doesn't seem to be the case here I'm
with King though the game passing
doesn't bother me as much because I've
always felt like they've hinted you know
this kids can't stay at this price
forever you know we can't stay at this
price for it like they've been saying
they've been throwing you the tea leaves
um with King though also or like I find
it absolutely hilarious that they have a
bomb show Xbox got gays ah they got
games you like you like this is like a
controlled we're stepping on a rake time
yeah like it's like we're gonna
intention step on the rake but it's just
like the timing of me is just I knew it
was gonna happen the question was when
and I understand though corporate Cog
understands because I knew they gotta do
it now because we we still off the
Euphoria of how great things are right
and before the decision on the ABK deal
is done because if it's done I feel
there's a strong chance you won't be
able to raise prices for a while because
the FTC said man all that stuff they're
looking at that to see if you are doing
nefarious things what's Call of Duty is
in your service and in your control what
I find very interesting is the series s
not moving on price so I look look at it
is like okay that's still what they view
as their entry point to get a person
because I think they have data right so
I'll wear 50 more than 50 percent of
people who are new to the Xbox ecosystem
bought a series s exactly so that to me
is still the entry point I am very
curious though if little
white bag
stays around yeah because if remember
Starfield
you saw it was 130 something gigs or
whatever it is right gonna have season
passes that's from what we see this is
the game that people like yo I am
looking to get an Xbox yeah so if they
come through on you know this on series
that's low man you know what I mean like
that's gonna be interesting you're gonna
need more hard drives because you got
Starfield you wanna you're gonna have
Game Pass and you're gonna be able to
download three games how much OS is
actually taking up let's left like 300
you left with 320 something hundred
something and you know we haven't talked
about it real quick well let me
interrupt you we just hit 17
000 so oh shout out to the people that
hitting that sub button we just salute
salute salute yes we we do owe you guys
the console giveaway yes uh somehow we
hit 2 000 after the console giveaway in
a matter of a month facts we had we had
15 000 a month ago so look you know I'm
very curious to see if it stays around
now this you know um little black man
comes around yeah they technically stay
around but you mysteriously won't be
able to find it
but another thing to think about is that
Western Digital just released their
versions of the SD cards that are much
cheaper than the other ones right so now
the idea of getting an OG little white
mix that's great the fact that we got
these names is out of pocket
it's it's more feasible now because
before we the argument could be made
just get a series X at that point right
because these things are so expensive
um but now I think though the Western
Digital cars are much cheaper for at
least the one terabyte so you can get
that and not break the bank and maybe
maybe be close to what you might pay for
the for the the black one terabyte
little man so
um yeah it was it was it'll stay around
OG little white man yo they stupid what
did you call them
I'm leaving that a little bit
there we go little black man
but the thing that I also find
interesting that's my last point is that
um you know as far as the Game Pass PC
game pass being unaffected very very
critical mess around okay mess around
with that people up like I said because
the PC they don't play that over there
but also remember they've they've
publicly stated they feel the console
Market is stacked as far as the
potential growth right so I think they
had numbers was it 200 they had like in
Crazy growth Targets in PC game pass so
it behooves them to continue that not to
put any roadblocks there to growth so I
thought that was interesting and yeah
y'all better re-up or before the price
is is attic says the price of brick
going up so you better re-up on these uh
services at that price because yeah it's
going down but yeah I get no one's
cheering for that we don't like that
kind of stuff but again I these I
understand the logic on why they're
doing the the timing that they're doing
things I just wanted to bring that to
the attention so yeah that's what I got
we are going to move on super chats
before the next one so super chats uh
and then I'll do my last read and then
we'll then we'll get to the last topic
yeah it's been a crazy day it's been
it's one of them days man yeah
[Music]
we didn't have any sponsors and we was
like please God please I know please
kind sir please God help us man because
we was out here you know and you know
what God Bless yeah she's a blessing
beautiful it's a blessing
all right we got Mandingo big Dickens
remember for two years two dollar Super
Chat all right so Cog likes beef noted
this whoa it's not like you scheming
whoa easy there
and we have Stitch remember for two
years five dollars is cog's only fans
page pick is it just him holding two
turkey drumsticks pause yo they out of
pocket right now
those those are honey turkey drinks
sweet talk
we we put seasoning on out there we
definitely yeah facts there's a lot of
seasoning over here a little bit of
ketchup on that too
I won't catch up in hot sauce yes that's
right on my wings let's go there we go
Nintendo yo taco man before one two
girls who's that Nintendo's the most
consumer friendly now right oh man
yes yes
a lean Graphics
they are the most cataract friendly
five dollars for chat did they raise the
price on both the X and the s or just
the X it was just X yeah either way I'm
not down for an increase yep that is
correct agreed then we got sanjitsu Sage
remember for 26 months Lord go the homie
homie the price increases will make more
sense when you see the rush to get
Hands-On and Xbox on an Xbox One star
fuel drops and one's Activision Blizzard
closes more will want Xbox game pass but
all won't have a PC there's a problem
with that statement it's it's a lot of
mystery it started gonna hit is the deal
gonna go through like it to me after
coming off of what uh you know a lot of
people felt you know include myself like
redfall is underwhelming after coming
off that game and increasing prices
that's where it sits bad with me it's
like you know at least when PlayStation
did it you could look at stuff like you
know they have Wolverine coming out they
they delivered a successful Spider-Man
you know last first one and two was good
you know goes to sushima you know like
we can't downgrade though I'm not even
paying attention to you right now yeah
we can't we can't downgrade the quality
of the games that PlayStation has
delivered does it does that mean they
should have raised their prices no but
at least when I looked at it on that end
it's like look at least they are
delivering games that you would
initially like to play now
it started would have came out and it's
mildly successful people love it highly
rated highly commercial successful then
it would have made a little bit more
sense to me logically but to me raising
it off of the condition they are go
they're in right now waiting for
Starfield and reasoning after they had
such a successful show is where I felt
like they really missed the mark
[Laughter]
[Music]
I was at Walmart yesterday and they
bundled Diablo 4 with series X's yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it's on the box are you serious
they got the marketing rights though so
I know but that is interesting nah it
was supposed to be in Game Pass
somebody was out there snitching the
lion
and we have zakari five dollars to be
chat Phil said yesterday's prices not
today's price it's still not cool though
yeah
then we got Pony up
glad I got my series X before they
announced the price increase the only
reason we have inflation is because of
Biden and Trump 2024 save Xbox shout out
to Pilots yeah your man might be in jail
buddy
time on politics
politics Matt without fear remember for
one year 10 pounds Super Chat uh if the
APK deal really does go through in the
next couple of weeks then they had uh to
get any price rise out before the before
that so it doesn't look like they're
proven proving any of Sony's concerns
correct true I I mean I once the once
it's done it's done you know what I'm
saying like it's one of those things
like you once they found OJ innocent you
know
are we really political today in the
realm
oh time on politics once the ink is is
on the contract it no matter what they
actually hear about Broncos or anything
else let's move on
yeah
20 super tents I believe didn't have a
choice but to raise prices
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh I believe Microsoft didn't have a
choice but to raise prices not just
because of inflation but also because of
Xbox Hardware remained the cheaper
option to some people it looks like
their Hardware when cheaper is a less
capable box yeah see that's the part
that I'm talking about and I think that
that mindset is faulty don't sit there
and raise it just to say no man we just
like them yeah you are not just like
them dudes you in third place you want
that Call of Duty you think that
showcase fire
don't do that man come on man get down
to lay down don't justify the gangster
get down later we got exclusive we got
games down huh
yeah yeah get down get down like that
you like that showcase
already increased from five to ten
dollars uh they did yeah that was a beta
thing though yes but it's still weird
that it was that they did a beta and
reduced the price on PC but not gone no
cities to say we paid for the lawyer
fees
[Laughter]
there we have Lieutenant Hulk
I like that we got breaking news Sony is
first in line to bid on WB movies and
games I hope Microsoft outbids them
don't want Batman as a Sony exclusive
okay first in line for the movies
[__] had a flash
I'm gonna be real if you like if they
are first line for the games like
Microsoft do
do not let them have DC and Marvel games
exclusive to their plans knock it out
the box fans don't want
hashtags they don't care about that they
said those
um
that will that would be such a bad thing
to do
sugar free to chat the homie too fat
there's not much news discuss this week
yeah we got a long show long show later
Flame
good afternoon IOP does anyone think Jim
flying lion hiding dancing in the rain
Ryan will ever say something truthful
before leaving the courtroom no I'm not
gonna feed anyone I won't see what the
statement
oh and we got flame once again two
dollars of attack congrats on 17. hey
IOP thank you the best Xbox podcast
around who said that who said that's
flame Messi get back to work
and we have rrjr 1017 2000 Super Chat
little black man with the big SSD
but this is true though facts and facts
then we have JD gamer remember for two
years ten dollars to be tap I don't like
the price increase but I get it still
sucks though and it's got to be a hard
position to be in no one wants to be
seen as cheap because the sum that means
less capable
we got DJ auros for two years congrats
on the 17K you guys deserve it hey
bestie
DJ what's going on then we have JD
Gamers for the crush of the chapter JD
gamer gifting five IOP memberships thank
you guys oh that's blessing the salute
that's love then we got Cedric H also
gifted five uh IOP memberships with the
crest in the chat for Cedric H thank you
guys appreciate that JD gamer 2 out
Super Chat let's keep those subs going
thank you oh thank you oh my god what
all right so Microsoft is one of the
potential buyers of square wait wait
wait where you hearing all this give me
some sauce I'm gonna send it to you
right these are these are the king
sauces or these are the sources you know
how sometimes the Kings you know the
underground
give us that dudes in the chat
sometimes we'll get a link that's like
this has no credible sources
exactly okay good
um
this is Bloomberg or Japan
oh
trust me bro
you scared bro
okay King yes Nick just completely
destroyed it got you man his favorite
article from
2021.news.com listen listen listen
whatever B
things take time things take time oh man
sick time Sunday oh yeah
you can take time son they say it's
still it's still cooking
yo
we got Mr two opinionated five dollars
in the chat I'm the reason for Bland all
Thor sorry Ram shout out to the Lord's
hashtag Started From The Bottom hashtag
extra seasoning oh man killing my homie
Dr Bland out though oh man I called
about we clarified we met in the Middle
Ground he's still a value he still
invited to the cookout
cause we put
barbecue sauce and sauces on the side
yeah
you don't like it he don't like it
drowned up bee yeah
[Applause]
let him bring McDonald's to the show
so what does he do when he eats like
Chicago Pizza like I'm listening yeah no
he's fine he's eating tomato sauce he's
fine yeah it's just like when he ordered
his wings he want the buffalo sauce and
all that to the side
so what's the king Network news
your baby forward that's wow he said he
got his sources from K and Ed
King News Network
yo that was Ill there we go k n okay
Sony's in Flames there will be an app
breaking news no PlayStation 6.
foreign
661 five dollar Super Chat first thing
my mind is first thing in my mind when
Phil
dubbed the Black Series S was thinking
on how you guys were having to update
the little man emoji you have on the
show
stickers thinking what attic show and K
n's like to say
hilarious then we have Vault chaplain
five dollars for chat breaking news
Microsoft acquired WB for 60 billion
that'd be crazy that'd be crazy back to
UK
yeah
then we got JD gamer again twenty
dollars for chat who got the games Xbox
got the games right to oh uh wh are your
games are so anywhere your games at Sony
about hellblade Fable Forza south of
midnight and more we ain't good over
here where are your games at oh Jesus
actually messy
then we have Michael Mooney five pound
Super Chat why would Mr Gunn take the DC
job if WB was going to sell DC right up
right from under him let's see
I ain't got nothing to do with nothing
this chick good then we got DJ oro's
2010 whoa I said yens
salute DJ they stretching this podcast
yeah they they killing us they're like
yo you gonna stay yeah we gonna get
these jokes off for y'all then we got JD
game again ten dollars Super Chat the
failed attempt at buying squares why
Xbox has been missing the big releases
the past two years Xbox ultimately
decided to Cuff up zenimax and square is
the bitter side piece sorry Square scars
Matt because they didn't get off with
the 60 million they would never get off
of 60. have you seen the state of Final
Fantasy okay
yeah we got apologies the Bronx is
Wildland today yeah
um
uh let's take a shot DJ Oro no shots on
the podcast we podcast
taking a shot every five minutes with us
yeah we got y'all baby father two
dollars I coined K N I want my residuals
he about to run to the FTC on us then no
I'm gonna call it uh KD and then
kick David
coin that thank you
last piece of business for the day oh
everybody might expire your hands we are
ready let's go this episode is brought
to you by bird dogs bird dogs is a
company that specializes in bringing you
the most comfortable shorts bathing
suits pants and polos on the market
they're specially engineered built-in
Comfort liners for their shorts and
pants offer any cross-disciplined
workout or Leisure activity which
enables customers to run swim and relax
all in the same pair of shorts or pants
so even if the prospect of technically
going commando doesn't get too excited
the fact of the matter is that bird dogs
just make you look good bird dog stretch
khakis and shorts are designed to fit
Slimmer through the thigh and leg giving
you a truly sculpted look
bird dog shorts do the exact same thing
as Lululemon shorts do but fit way way
better they also fit way better than
regular shorts and pants that are made
of stiff restricting cotton bird dogs
has fixed this issue by inventing Cloud
knit fabric
so you get a way Slimmer fit without
having to sacrifice movement bird dogs
also uses anti-stink sweat sweat wicking
fabric that keeps you cool and dry all
day long so for me my dress style has
changed a lot since my younger days as
someone who probably took the whole
baggy Trend a little too far throughout
the 90s as a 47 year old man I now
prefer to to wear you know more form
flattering more form-fitting look to my
wardrobe so that I can accentuate this
uh adonis-like body that I have chiseled
to Perfection over my nearly half
century of existence but no the fact is
that someone who is constantly on the
move and sweats profusely like me bird
dogs allows me to stay cool dry and
flexible throughout my ever hectic days
additionally and this is just a cool
side note I love you know supporting
companies that I just have fun with the
brand I love the naming conventions that
they have for their products with polos
that are called Jacques straps shorts
such as Teddy rubskins and tight wads
and pants called John D coxmellers and
Lee I did a lot of Coca so if you're
ready to join me and finally dress like
an adult and show off those massive
quads and calves it's time to get bird
dogs so go to birddogs.com pool and
enter promo code pool p-o-o-l for a free
Yeti style tumbler with your order
that's bird dogs bird dogs.com slash
pool for free Yeti style tumbler you
won't want to take your bird dogs off we
promise you oh man so we Commando with
it
oh man your pants fit like Lulu
Hey DJ orange
I'm not gonna lie
bird dogs like um because uh like one of
the places that I have downtown when I
go downtown let's get out the car the
store's right there and
for people that um like you know y'all
wear those shorts and the shorts don't
look right it don't feel right they have
like little creases this is just you
just look bad in your shorts these
shorts definitely work and the fact that
you know sometimes I just don't be
really feeling like Grandma yeah
swagging oh listen man I mean I'm gonna
tell you right now sometimes you gotta
run in the store you just got you know
the only truly free beings in the world
are babies right babies
they eat when they hungry they sleep
when they're tired they get fed when
they're so it is so to me as an adult
with all this responsibility I'm like
let what what can I take off the plate
there
why is
[Music]
I mean I'll be sure
let's go let's go
show your dogs everybody gotta show it
everybody we gotta stand up we gotta do
the oh no is Alex
hold on pull it back pull it back you
got the cast account
we get the bird dogs where they come
through because they come through right
so if I am back oh yeah we got attic
slap the thigh we gonna do this
DJ almost said only cast.com
I already have I already have a pair
because I have bird dogs from before
because you know like I said let's go
we got the casting couch ready
what we call that cause we got chunky we
got beefy
why this is why you love Iron Lords
adderies nobody nobody gives you average
like that nobody giving you that we
didn't throw back up we ain't got no
Adry like a exactly let's move over the
show
Square just wants a little love folks
and somebody over there smooth talking
that left ear that's real hot and
bothered but totally neglecting them
thighs them big thighs
Square be patient we coming for you oh
that was extra
oh 12 90 likes y'all oh man we got more
likes than the viewers right that's
crazy 1172 ill that's love well we
caught up let's finish this track
just gave up yeah Final Fantasy 16. I've
just submitted uh King this is
technically your topic with attic kind
of mixed in on his Impressions so should
I set this up Sir let me get my stuff
out yeah
that's my topic I get to say what I want
to do
I do not want to pass the football son
all right you want to do all right so um
you're back in the running back yes so
so basically
um Final Fantasy 16 reports players are
reporting major frame rate issues on
Playstation 5. so the issue comes down
to if you want to put it in performance
mode and where it attempts to get to um
60 frames per second but they said
generally Final Fantasy 16 Target 16
often managed comes closer it drops down
to 40 frames per second the resolution
may drop all the way down to 720p in
order to do it I do what he doing and
doing it it hit 60 frames so it's having
a lot of issues they said mostly mostly
because some of the ray tracing is
trying to be responsible for some of the
performance issues and other graphical
settings and then they're also saying
the graphics mode is also having some
issues where to keep it at a started a
steady 30. yeah because what they said
and the fellately is causing the new
release to suffer from May major motion
blur so if you're putting it on on
Graphics mode there's currently no way
to turn off motion blur in Final Fantasy
16 and the only recommendation they can
make to alleviate is issues by playing
in frame rate mode but for those who
play frame rate mode it could drop as
low as 720. so King what about the
overheating and fires oh my God that was
weird
Final Fantasy 16 intense boss fights
um it's reportedly causing PlayStation 5
consoles to overheat this is from
Twisted voxel.com
it's like one of those things here it's
uh you bring it up and it's like and
we're going live to the scene
he got one of them sites so yeah people
with Early Access to copies of Final
Fantasy 6 have recently reported that
the game tends to overheat their
PlayStation 5 console during certain
boss fights and Twitter users vs k n
energy spear Hunter stated that it has
yeah that the boss fights the marble
boss is what is PlayStation 5 showed a
message stating that the console needed
to be turned off in order to cool this
is ridiculous all right regardless of
what it's a common problem they're
saying and that um previously it was
reported
yeah that's pretty much she actually cut
I love quinoa General King to come up
for this this is ridiculous
it's a king clearly you wanted to talk
about this this is your topic sir
so y'all want me to put Final Fantasy
into my PlayStation so I can hear Scotty
yell out I'm giving it all she got
captain
she can't hold it Captain she's
overheating we need to shut her down
no put it in put it in 720 mode Captain
it's the only way we can get out of this
boss fight
the dragon's fight is hot captain
put it in performance mode no that's
worse
graphical demotion blur is killing us
you're ridiculous
our DNA what half of one yeah I got a
half hour dude
that came there like her ice isn't
enough to keep us cold
put it in a bucket rip the wings
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
I showed all those boss fights not one
time did I see it said time out shut it
off
shout out the digital Foundry for
finally doing a job oh finally
I love of this [__] and it's only on
y'all you're only holding yourself back
oh because it's exclusive that's why you
go ahead because it's exclusive yeah
they can't play King so it's a blow in
the controller Captain it's overheating
blowing in controller
that kid okay oh my God this is the best
yeah King King you know on the back of
the Final Fantasy case it says requires
a fan you know when you hear your
PlayStation ramp up
mm-hmm
yeah you hear it transformed
these guys
you don't need you don't need thousands
of dollars for a heating system you need
a 500 console and a seventy dollar okay
it's come with an AC unit
so why is my final fantasy 500 it come
with a portable AC unit they got okay
they got so many complaints Walmart
bundling fans with the PlayStation so
you're gonna need this what the hell is
that that's a fan
yo
that's all I got
because obviously y'all have given me
much joy
of everybody that kept for this game
that's still kept
yo yo PlayStations are literally
crashing and burning
y'all playing a live action crashing
not crashing bird not the 3D old games
now you know the pecking order
about the 7 30 PK not like this y'all
the best son
I count on y'all every week to bring
news like this straight to me live from
K N
back to you Jim
thank you for your timely reporting uh I
don't have much to say but I'm pretty
much tapped out on this so we want to
move on we can move on unless anyone
else has something to say what about
Final Fantasy yeah okay live report
whatever
so I played probably about seven or
eight hours it smells smoke
no my PlayStation is still intact I will
say that that's good the biggest thing I
will say is I'm starting to fill this
game like I feel like uh you know uh
breath of the wild and Fallout 4 like
they're great games but it's not a good
Final Fantasy game you know Final
Fantasy about creative freedom build the
character you want to build now sure
some of them go away from it like 10
with the sphere grid where you know you
can't switch your jaws per se but you
could still get all the abilities that
you want now this is pretty much like
you get what you get uh I do think that
they sacrificed a lot of the
customization that comes with most Final
Fantasy games for like telling us a
well-toed story in a high graphic
surrounding uh is that the best case
scenario probably not I think a lot of
people would want more I noticed that
there's like less when it comes to job
systems like as a nun almost there's not
really a whole lot going with the
element system in the game you know it
is that bad
for a final fantasy fan I would say it
is you know I I remember in in Final
Fantasy 10 trying to you know make
characters that you would be able to do
unique things with go after certain
abilities you know uh Titus usually was
a you know a faster character I remember
you know using return spheres to go up
different Avenues to make him just as
strong as Aaron at the beginning of the
game you know the class system from like
five where you can mention uh Miss and
match where you can have the mimic where
you just keep doing Ultima over and over
again because you just need one person
to cast it you have everyone else use
mimic
that is a lot of the case scenarios
where I feel like Final Fantasy really
excels but what I will say about this
game
is as much as I love seven
oh I feel more drawn to this story
stories fire yes uh it does feel very
adult-like now that's that doesn't mean
that like final fantasy's never told an
adult story correct they've told a lot
of adult stories but the problem is
they've never had the technology and
they've never went this far you know you
you playing like three or four hours and
you just literally people butt ass naked
just sitting there talking on on a bed
about what they gonna do it and it's
just like you never really saw that in
Final Fantasy you yeah you know and what
I like about this game too is like it's
I don't know what's coming at the
beginning they're like yo you know uh
you're you're you betrayed us and I'm
thinking we gonna fight a little bit
and then we're going to come to an
agreement and he's going to be my
teammate nah I killed that dude
so it's just I I appreciate that you
know a lot of people came at me they're
uh you know one of the reasons that I
was showing uh Final Fantasy eight uh
attic you ain't played Past final
fantasies you can't really talk about
that I don't know why they said that
maybe it's newer I know we've been
growling a lot I've played almost every
Final Fantasy you can think of I played
tactics Advance I've played a lot of the
spin-offs I even played uh I even beat
Final Fantasy X-2 and a lot of people
didn't like that game play 12 and it's
sequel that was on like the Game Boy the
PSP I can't remember which handheld it
was on it's like look there's a lot of
things that make Final Fantasy Final
Fantasy and I will say 16's missing the
majority of it but what 16 does very
well is keep you engaged in a story tell
you a narrative that makes sense in a
lot of ways and it is good more than it
is bad now I will criticize the fact
that I felt like Zelda yo you you took
away my Dungeons and you gave me okay
Dungeons and bad dungeons so I feel like
this you got you you took my final
fantasy brand you towed it in a better
way than it's ever been told but you
took a lot of the side pieces that made
Final Fantasy Final Fantasy yeah and
that's pretty much all I do enjoy it I
really enjoy it you know I I want to
just turn off this stuff now and go play
oh the story I enjoy the game but I will
say it's like how I feel like breath of
the wild love breath of wild love tears
of the Kingdom you know love Fallout 4
thought it was a great game thought all
these games were worthy of Game of the
Year contenders but when you compare
them to their predecessors they fall
short in almost every lane
fair enough fair enough software you
want me to jump because
no no I didn't I didn't play beyond the
demo like I said I thought about it I
was like I'm not gonna get this right
now yeah I can't play it right now
I'll jump in no look um exciting he's
still I gotta actually I'm gonna say but
I gotta play more post demo but I I find
it interesting the the discourse because
you have the hardcore or Final Fantasy
fans who are saying you know they don't
feel it's you know a pure Final Fantasy
game with the turn base and things of
that nature and then you have people and
it's like just a turd based on it's like
I said like the job system's not really
there like there's a lot of
customization of final fantasies there's
been very few final fantasies that have
in-depth customization and let you fight
the way you want to fight and almost all
of that's not here no I get it and then
there's people you know so that's like
the purest perspective that you have
people who you know who like the new
change who like that it's a Devil May
Cry kind of action combat and their tone
and a serious story so it depends where
you're at with it you know I'm curious
to see you know where it ends my main
issue is obviously King clowned on the
performance which you know hopefully
they patch and fixes I didn't I didn't
realize I felt it was uneven but I
didn't realize it was dropping that low
to try to maintain the 60 or whatever
but it's a philosophy thing I just think
that they're looking at it like hey each
way we come out each time we come out
we're gonna try to reinvent ourselves
and it's it's polarizing maybe in that
expense respect to the purists but I'm
curious to see reception wise and sales
wise how they do but I've been liking it
I've been liking it so far so I'm gonna
get back to it I'm gonna wear both
because I'm trying to finish Diablo and
get that done and then I wanna I wanna
get to it but I will definitely get to
it and this is probably one of the first
Mainline final fantasies that really
excited me in a while so we should see
and it's one of those things where it's
like look I get it there's a lot of cut
scenes but the thing is it's like I
don't mind the cutscenes as long as I'm
engaged and I actually care about what
happens next time you know I get it
people are like you it's not really
in-depth combat like if you break things
down you know you don't have to play
this game on like hard difficulties or
anything like that if you play and you
just strictly stick to the root of the
combat system it might not engage you as
much because I think a lot of it is like
people compare this like Devil May Cry
it's nothing like Devil May Cry in terms
of combat but what I will say is I do
feel fluid when I play the combat I mean
it's something special it's something
fantastic but it is fun yeah fair enough
look that's what matters at the end of
the day Final Fantasy in the books uh
super chassis the final topic or you
want to just back to back let me get
these these super chats because they
coming in Crazy Joker of course all
right
good save there sir David gamer remember
folks do you want pretty graphics and a
push X to play button with no ability to
interact with anything in the
environment at 720p or do you want uh if
you see it you can interact with the
game at 4K you know what this is this is
the Starfield game Revenge this is
Starfield gang is outside with this and
what what I will say is even though I I
don't care about the stuff logistically
but perception wise you can't go out
there and attack a game for Camp running
something at 60 when you're just
completely overlooking again going to
720p which was the 360 error when you
you don't see games going that far down
a resolution anymore I don't care
well because I'll be playing because it
doesn't really bother me per se
especially I'm more on the frame rate as
long as that frame rate where it feels
doesn't feel like a PowerPoint I'm okay
with that resolution as long as it's not
there like all the time I'm okay with
that uh but it is what it is like I If
you go to throw stones don't be mad when
King and his army throws rocks at you
later that's all this is because they
came for the Starfield delegation
because it was like it was exclusive and
you can't hit 60 on your own console and
now they're gonna say that there's no
PS4 here there you already know what
this is
yeah put it in graphical mode it's crazy
they'll put in performance mode crazier
take the Wings off them leave them naked
in the room
your joint can't take it captain
I can't see you Star Trek this is where
you you gotta love my knowledge son
then we got void lock member for two one
year two dollars so the PS5 went from a
router to a toaster slash Grill
then we got JD Gaber remember for two
years she's not super sad nah son you
live by the ff6 you die by the ffcs
yeah we got bad dick go big Dickens
remember for two years five dollars if
PS5 can't run a corridor structure nine
hour cinematic field game at 720 40 FPS
what makes what what makes ponies
believe that PS5 ponies believe that PS5
he he wrote knees k-n-e-e-s very nice
believe that PS5 can run Starfield yet
Series S
uh it's running it then we got Matt
without fear remember for 17 months Lord
silver never mind performance mode for
ff16 where's the RPG mode
or RPG mechanics in sight this is Final
Fantasy Devil May Cry
it is that's what it is they like it I
like it they like it they're talking
about Game of the Year please
I got JD gave him a game remember for
two years too loud so what's that
somebody found this dude he's too hot go
get help
I heard the game is Co-op your partner
sits there with a fan
a second screen beat that boss
that's like okay it's like those those
uh movies where you see like the people
with the giant Elise
you sitting there like this
that boss fight is intense
the room's so hard the the TV just
completely turns off from being
overheated no you see a bunch of dudes
playing with their shirt off
I see a lot of pepperonis what's
happening time
I can't wait
we got DJ quaros remember for two years
two dollars which have four more hours
no no no no getting out of here now we
just gotta get to this Nintendo Direct
we all agree it's dope
we got uh Stu Jersey remember for two
months put the Chris in the chat for
Stewie Jersey Lord Bronx appreciate you
stupid Jersey we got JD gamer hold up we
gotta jump uh give me a sec okay JD
gamer two dogs who was that ff6 all
popping all Pomp and Circumstance and no
depth no depth okay I I did not concur
we'll leave that there
change the gamer too long ff6 is like a
Quantic greens game press x two play do
you mean 16. he keeps forgetting yeah
like that you mean like that yeah he
lost 10 other ones
JD Garrett let's just submit ff16 is an
interactive movie okay you mean
one more time who got the games Xbox got
the games where your games at Sony about
people south of midnight and Forza we
ain't good over here here we go RDJ five
dollars to be tap shout out to ff16
putting in a fake performance mode to
avoid backlash waiting for them
yeah I got the option then we got JD
gave her five dollars if we try to get
somebody help they got Vaseline in their
eyes because I know this game not
running at 720p somebody lying to me PS3
did that okay I got PS5 is great is
equal to PS3 wow
okay yeah just having fun today
we caught up all right let's finish this
stuff
oh Nintendo Direct self this is you yeah
Nintendo Direct man they Nintendo
dropped it directed I think most people
were like I don't think it's gonna be
anything great you know are they gonna
capitalize on the success of the Mario
movie are they gonna do this are they
gonna do that it was pretty quiet and
they dropped this and to be honest they
have the number two uh they have the
number two press conference of the
summer but if I'm calculating correctly
because they came out and they did they
they did what Nintendo does they give
you reasons to spend money on their
platform by hitting your Nostalgia then
hitting on upon things you had no idea
would come in and then just you know
sprinkling in a bunch of other stuff to
keep their other games alive but so the
the main thing is to come out of this
direct right first and foremost
they've given us a remake of Mario RPG
locked off on uh like a virtual console
and uh and and the SNES because I don't
think they brought it to
um many consoles I don't think they've
done that right because it's it the the
right stuff with Square Enix in them is
kind of like it's it's messy so um they
finally got it together and figured it
out and this remake looks beautiful it
is absolutely beautiful still in that
style little little chunky that little
chunky stuff yeah budgie style pudgy
style um beefy baby
and then they announced people love this
detective Pikachu Pikachu comes back and
detective Pikachu with Pikachu talking
like a grown ass
voice man that likes coffee but again
this is super popular take a rest of
Logan exactly they're going to remaster
Luigi's Mansion uh two Dark Moon that
was the 3DS version they could remaster
that so again Nintendo getting you to
pay brand new money for old games but
prettier on the switch but they're the
best at doing that and we happily do it
yeah yeah Princess Peach is finally
getting her own game after not getting
one for a long time I remember super
Princess Peach on the DS
just when we think they don't know how
to capitalize on stuff
they do it you know um Batman Arkham
Trilogy coming to it we'll see yeah
that's the lean Edition I will say I
don't know I don't know how Arkham
Knight does the other two can probably
do okay I don't know what Arkham Knight
is this not available already at the
trilogy for the PC or the consoles it is
basically they have the Arkham
collection which is supposed to be the
same it's the same thing so there's a
collection that has all of the old cons
all of them except the WV Montreal are
the words and they always keep that one
to the side and there's no up Fresno 660
you know no yeah
because the way it was when I saw this I
thought it was like brand new that the
only thing they got this Nintendo okay I
don't know I'll be honest I don't know
if the collection's on on Xbox and
Playstation yeah because I've never
pressed to them I have the games yeah
right we got the game individually the
biggest yeah the biggest thing is they
getting this thing to run on that thing
oh stop this you want to know if it's
going to be a Star Trek situation
oh they can run that [__] when you
playing it your wing your little uh
nerves pop off
the Mario
[Laughter]
so yeah we got that we got some DLC for
Sparks of Hope coming out we got a new
Dragon Quest game called monsters I
don't know I think it's coming out to
everything but again they got the
announce trailer we got Pikmin four
coming in hot people love their pigment
and and they Shadow dropped one and two
uh available right now
um so again they know how to get people
to spend money the Metal Gear Solid
Master collection
um on the in the PlayStation showcases
coming to them as well yes um vampire
survivors St again King coming yeah wait
I want to see that system blow up yo we
I even the single player game I feel
would be kind of crazy when it gets
Bonkers on the switch it's about four
player co-op now hold on hold on there's
a little big switch gang this big switch
you ain't had that mode it does Xbox
have that move it should I mean they
announced it at a switch thing but it
really I don't know but I've switched
guys
and we got more courses of Mario Kart we
got a 3D platformer called Penny's big
Breakaway which looks very very cool but
people who who keep tired of asking
Microsoft for banjo to come back this is
it
um we gotta remake of Star Ocean 2
coming out to multiple platforms not
coming to Xbox unfortunately
um but Star Ocean 2 who is an amazing
old school game and it looks beautiful
the way they remade it I like store
auction we got another Mario coming a
Wario where sorry Mario uh Warrior we're
coming in a lot of people didn't like
the last one so much
um as much as old Wario wear so this is
cool
um then we got amiibos coming in
we got Zelda and hot what they what
they've done this hot Ganondorf yo
people loving how brolic Gannon is
looking like a little beefy beefy
could be using products
what we need to do for uh if we ever
make Evo for that just have cause Avatar
say beefy
yo I got a point at the screen and then
we have the cake topper the return of 2D
Mario Brothers Super Mario Brothers
Wonder Hey look this game like I saw
this game and this this is this is proof
positive that when is doing his genius
thing
he is tripping balls when he's doing
this Komodo is about that life he about
that person I don't know what it is and
this game Super Mario Brothers wonder I
I am fully convinced that he actually
wanted to call this game Super Mario
Brothers Molly and he could not call it
Molly this is mushrooms mushrooms and he
says no me Immortal we can't call it
Molly we just flipped it just flip the M
around and make a word out oh I wonder
wonder who Mario Brothers
it is proof positive that Mario has
always about always been about what
happens when he takes those mushrooms
and
the psychedelics that happened yo I'm
telling you and they finally just
literally leaned into it and now you
have you have the Wonder flower
miraculously changes the aspect of every
single stage once you once you consume
them all right uh-huh and this is
looking like a fever dream like I have
never seen and I'm here for it I'm here
this me Immortal is at his best is when
he's in he's in this is how he came up
with Pikmin he's in the yard he's you
know gardening quote-unquote gardening
and and these are the things that happen
so I'm excited for about real brothers
wonder they really drop some bangers
here like we said before it's surprising
but it is true 2D Mario sells more than
3D Mario
um and we have we have a 2d brand new 2D
Mario coming out right the same week
that we getting Spider-Man it's in the
mix and it really I'm gonna be honest
they shocked me with this Nintendo
Direct we're looking at kind of the end
of the life cycle of the switch right
should be getting there yeah
um and you don't expect for them to be
dropping games like this you said you
expect for them to hold this for the
next thing but then maybe the next thing
isn't the closest we hope it is you know
um but they this is kind of a little bit
of a banger
I was very excited for this and Mario
seems like it's again a lot of people
were not happy with the new Super Mario
Brothers designs and this looks very
cartoonish they're very emotive like the
the facial expressions like it seems
like they've done some work to that
animation so yeah I'm excited for this
and I I it was weird but most of the
internet was excited too like oh the
Nintendo kind of brought it like in a
way that we didn't expect so yeah what
do y'all think attic
I thought it was a
a great direct you know I'm very curious
because I I had ever played Mario RPG
and this is and by the time that like I
heard of that game
it was like it was just too late it was
like one of those things where you hear
about it's like I just wait for the
Remake but it never came right so now I
have the opportunity to play it uh I I
I'm very very excited to try it out as
far as like the rest of the games
there's probably like one of the real
only games that really vibed with me I'm
not really a big Mario 2D person but I
will try it out when it comes out you
know down I think you'll like Star Ocean
attic you definitely like stars King
your thoughts on the direct Nintendo
outside
um I thought they hit it out the park Oh
I thought that um that was the second
best show this year if not tied with
Microsoft show
um they showed exclusives they showed a
willingness to compete
when going up against
um putting their best IP up against
Spider-Man
um Nintendo showed you with
supposedly 8th gen Hardware
that they're not afraid like it just it
doesn't matter and they really have the
post on of their community
they understood that Super Mario the
movie was a thing
and whatever they had in the cooker they
accelerated this stuff to get this stuff
out the door in a timely fashion that's
this is this year's stuff yeah it's
crazy that's what makes it when you talk
about maybe they tied Microsoft it's the
fact that three of these joints are
coming out this year yeah
so it's this is this is going to be one
of the best years on paper
and we know that majority of those games
is going to be certified bangers yeah so
and the DLC for the Mario Kart and stuff
like that it's just
um if if you have a switch you have
enough stuff to play oh yes and I think
that's the best part right so I I walked
away from it because I remember Aquino
hit me and he was like a Nintendo switch
direct and I was like whatever
I was laying there doing nothing I was
tired I was like let me get some rest
before I go to work and I put it on and
I wind up watching the whole direct now
I had a problem with my audio because it
was telling giving me audio for games
that wasn't being shown so I had to
watch it on um I think it was twitch I
went to Twitch and watched the
rebroadcast of it on Twitch and um I saw
that saw it in his entirety I was like
whoa a lot of those games that I'm
really uh stoked for you know and then
for people that didn't have a didn't
play Batman and this is your only
console I'm gonna get that game on that
yeah it's like that you can't say
they're not trying
Nintendo has shown
that they don't need third-party support
in order to be great on Call of Duty
right and Call of Duty is not thinking
like you're taking this somewhere yeah I
feel like he's taking it somewhere no
Call of Duty is not there yet Call of
Duty will be there you know the next
next iteration of the console with the
10-year deal that they signed with
Microsoft ensures a Call of Duty to be
there you know so when the deal goes
through you know Nintendo definitely has
a benefit and I think they have an
incentive in order to uh mitigate uh
uh Spider-Man's importance in the uh
Marketplace knowing that their partners
with Microsoft you know and it was just
another smack in Sony's face like sign
the contract B
you out here causing the stir
we're just trying to compete so I think
they competed at the highest level they
respected out of everybody
Microsoft and Nintendo respected
tradition in the month of June where
it's supposed to be E3 month and it's
supposed to be about games and it's
supposed to be about your exclusives and
it's supposed to be about what you got
coming out and it's supposed to be about
what you're giving to your fans where
Sony is lacking snitching and crying
these dudes is out here performing so
hats off to Nintendo and Microsoft and
and Jeff you know and you know Sony pick
your game up bro yeah well here we say
it definitely a surprise um they
definitely uh did they think I didn't
expect this direct I didn't expect this
level of quality from them you know and
like you said it's all a lot of stuff
coming you know this year for me to
stand out I'm like um addict I've never
played uh Super Mario RPG
that looked fine
it was the fact that square was a part
of it yes yeah it was one of the first
times that Nintendo let anybody mess
with their eyes people are excited
Nintendo facts that's a huge deal shout
out to hustle and motivate who we had on
he used to talk about that like that was
his that was what kind of got him into
that um that system really really well
so yeah that looked bad dope fit to my
sensibilities I'm in on that I love the
Metal Gear Solid collection I I got this
thing kick I want to go back to Metal
Gear Solid 2 on the boat remember
I missed that game that game was a
graphical showpiece for its time we
played that demo
bro that made Playstation everybody
for that game I didn't even play that
game [__] I didn't even play it Hustler
motivate episode 165 yeah bro I remember
you was going in on a Subaru but yeah
metal gets solid those were my joints
and that was the debut of raid in the
controversy
oh we got past the Big Show who the hell
is this dude why I can't play mistake
though remember with the big controversy
at the time you know what I'm saying
nobody knew about Raiden we got that
vampire Survivor eightier gave it's good
to see them got that eight-tier game
there
I don't care what you will feel try to
bully me in the New York game boy it's
about but um yeah it's cool
four player cards I'm very curious I'm
assuming Xbox should get that right
which one four player co-op vampire yeah
I'm assuming I'm assuming that's not an
exclusive no one ever said nothing I
never heard it's my first time hearing
about it I I want to I want y'all to try
to do it
[Music]
Nintendo has been known to come in and
snatch like exclusive like couch Co-op
type of content before so yeah it might
be couch Co-op yeah it might be couch
course it is local it is local so it's
not online so Xbox might not have that
yeah
up and it might be uh what is it uh the
what 20 80 like I tell Nana uh 280i yeah
I got like Fair pass if I was pushing
Graphics
no when you get all the Sprites so I
know where y'all going y'all talking
about CPU bound up by how much enemies
on the screen I know where you're going
I know what you're doing a little
straight up yeah
Batman Arkham was was cool and um salute
the rabbits getting the DLC because I
heard that initially didn't do well the
second time around but to see them still
support that yeah yeah America eight man
I'm sorry
edmo talked about that he was like we
kind of made a mistake of releasing it
on this generation of we should have
held the sequel for the next generation
of console because it's like the way he
said it was yeah it was more the same he
was like it was more the same it was
good but in order to excite people you
need you need to pair that with maybe
new exciting Hardware whatever the case
may be they should have just left it for
a launch game for whatever the next
switch would be and that would have been
fantastic but again yeah yeah no Mario
Kart they are milking that thing to the
end bro it's such a money maker yep it
plays such a money maker and the last
thing I saw the attic shirt yeah shout
out to attic shirt um I do not care
about piggy man I peek him in I don't
care about Pokemon I don't care about
none of that but I can't deny the impact
I can't deny what those do you know what
I'm saying so they're they're ending the
year massive they're ending it massive
so we'll see what's up shout out to the
old school you know a little beef going
on they dropping around the same time
cool to see Sonic on their um on that
stage what is it the um what's it called
the All-Stars uh All-Stars I'm loving
that song let me get it right before
everyone and yeah four plus four player
co-op in that Sonic too yes and that
Sonic is foreplay so yeah yeah yes
break protocol
off right yeah okay we're gonna have a
born Saga five dollars to attack why are
we not talking about the face of all the
centuries Sonic Superstars and the
Face-Off of the century uh Sonic
Superstars and Mario Wonder drop within
three days of each other hashtag free
free knocks
no it's not a Face-Off Rogers versus
Spider-Man it's the crazy yeah that's
the Face-Off yes you know Sonic is just
fighting for shelf space
ever boy Freda bro I've done anyway yeah
so he yo he he gladly admitted that he
did it yeah like it better admit it you
know he did it but anyway look that's
all I got great show Nintendo little
little happy that they they ended well
but a little sad I'm like damn we still
gotta wait for this switch this thing
ready to finish again at some point if
Something's Gonna Be cross-gen Right a
lot of this but I'll say within the next
six months we'll hear about their next
shot I think so man I I can see I can
see it they never they haven't done it
but I could see Akili announce in a
March April for release or a March April
announced a holiday release like yeah
but we'll see but I could also see them
not doing not doing it and making mad
money off Pokemon and mad money on
Pokemon winning game of the year with
the foreign
[Music]
let me see JD gave her five dollar Super
Chat don't worry PlayStation fans all
you have to do is hold the lock
all right this is what we're going to do
because we want out here everyone mute
your mic but him
we have Nintendo Taco Super Chat Xbox
and Nintendo stomping out the
PlayStation showcase bad
then let's put the crest of the chapter
stage 1X welcome to the realm LeBrons
salute we got JD gamer too though Super
Chat Lords when are we getting the new
Switch console yes what are we going to
do switch console I've been waiting
Nintendo Taco five dollar Super Chat I
have hated the 2D Mario since new Super
Mario Brothers you it was so stale
before but now I'm beyond hype it looks
amazing yes it does I love the animation
and we got Butterball eight
that moment that Super Mario wonder and
Spider-Man 2 come out the same day yeah
yeah yeah that's awesome man
then we got Nintendo Super Chat Mia
model said take a hit of my uh of this
Mario Juana yo yo that's ill that was
Ill
it's probably exactly how I went down
too
I have it tied with Xbox with an 8.5
higher highs than Xbox as far as newer
reels way more gameplay and sooner
releases but much lower lows okay no
doubt no doubt no doubt Super Metro at
Super Metroid Lord Metro chat Sega slash
Sonic saw the direct and said man I
wonder
[Laughter]
this is Mario Molly that's what I'm
calling it
Nintendo Super Chat uh uh Super Mario
RPG is more Final Fantasy than Final
Fantasy 16. yo six you keep seeing six
it's 16. yeah
yo they do got that RPG system I mean it
is a straight up RPG it's pretty easy
but it's it's time it's kind of perfect
we're not saying anything right oh three
five seven ten dollars in the chat great
so the FTC is some clowns Xbox got
fentanyl lace crack whoa the Nintendo
Direct was like seeing a dried up cow
still getting suckled just about Jesus
Christ time could continue
ever born already got this one Nintendo
Taco two dollars which I ever born
that's not a Face-Off that's a beat deck
then we got JD gamer five dollars to
chat we are not getting a switch to
until they sell 156 million units they
want that number one position we'll get
a switch too but what's the question
called oh my God he's ready he's ready
all right uh people surprised you have
you eaten cat addicted I'm starving too
I am starving too ILP pole for the
Hungry with Microsoft claiming that Sony
actively signs third-party games to skip
their platform to try and reduce Xbox's
Survival on the market how do you feel
Xbox should respond if true the joys are
a invest more in their currently owned
Studios to compete B signed third-party
exclusive games of their own C acquire
more Studios for ownership or D I don't
care put the FTC on the stand themselves
that is the question those are the votes
please rock that out on Twitter when it
goes absolute everybody to chat salute
to the like salute to the supporting us
during the reads just salute everything
all around y'all be rocking with us hard
body and it's cool to see the podcast
grow the way it is growing and yeah
nothing but love shout out to drive by
Joe my head at two dollar Super Chat
hold the stream know we are not holding
the streets not doing that to us now we
know how y'all get down lord addict
where can the power people find you
because you know what they're trying to
do you can find me on Twitter at lordop
I'm on YouTube and get me edit see you
guys next week
there you go lord it's off we can find
people find you you can find him on
Twitter as well
work goodbye work goodbye Lord King
which you got going on Sir find me
sleeping I guess I got to get up at 1pm
to go to work I feel like get that sleep
on anyway see y'all next week nor fun
more things planned and salute on the
was it 17K we did that love y'all we're
not holding the stream I'm sitting I'm
sending you guys to Jamaican gamer
because he's the only person on see you
guys all right
oh man one more shot okay you do that
bro
one more shot and go in there and show
some love Jamaican game everybody
first two dollars all right peace
thank you
[Music]
foreign